Ah, yes, excellent.
Aufwacht, Champ.
Leute, das mit dem Champ,
das hat sich so
eingebürgert bei mir,
irgendwie so eingeschliffen bei mir.
Ich nenne mittlerweile auf der Arbeit
mittlerweile schon
irgendwelche komischen Programme,
die ich mache,
Champ hintendran.
Ich habe letztens was gebastelt,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe.
Das habe ich wahrscheinlich schon 50 Mal erzählt,
weil ich das so geil fand.
Irgendeiner auf der Arbeit hat,
das ist egal wer,
hat so eine Auswertung programmiert,
um Zugriffe über einen Proxy zu zählen.
Also sprich, der hat
quasi alle Log-Dateien genommen
und hat dann
hat die durchgegrappt,
durchsucht nach Aufrufen
im Squid.
Und dann hat er halt einfach gezählt,
wie oft die Sachen vorkommen.
So, und das hat er in Bash gemacht,
also Linux Shell.
Und das lief in der Testumgebung
eine Woche,
eine Woche
lief die Log-Auswertung
mit seinem Bash-Skript.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
So, und da habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, das kann es jetzt ja nicht sein.
Also,
habe ich ein .NET-Programm gebastelt,
den Log-Champ,
wo wir am Thema sind.
Also, wie gesagt,
ich nenne mittlerweile auf der Arbeit
auch den ganzen Kram schon irgendwie
irgendwas mit Champ, ja.
Und der Log-Champ
hat das Gleiche dann gemacht,
wie das Bash-Skript
und das war in 15 Minuten.
Sag mal, in der Testumgebung
15 Minuten und in der Live-Umgebung
würde ich sagen so 35 Minuten.
Aber das sind ja auch wirklich
massive viele Logs gewesen, ja.
Hat er, sag mal, in einer halben Stunde
15 bis 30 Minuten durchsucht,
da wäre das Bash-Skript wahrscheinlich
irgendwie einen Monat oder so gelaufen,
keine Ahnung.
Und das war schon nice.
Das hat natürlich den Server
komplett dicht gemacht, ja.
Ich habe das, ich habe das
multi-threaded eingestellt
und das lief halt
auf 12 Kern
und hat, also der Server hat 24,
aber ich habe es auf 12 beschränkt.
Das Ding ist einfach,
hat den Server komplett dicht gemacht.
Sogar so dicht,
dass die Java-Anwendung
darauf ab und zu hing,
weil das Ding muss ab und zu mal
Garbage collecten
und da hat es nicht genug
CPU-Kerne für Garbage.
Ich wusste auch nicht,
dass es Java schafft,
24 CPU-Kerne nur mit
Garbage-Collection auszulassen.
Logs, Squidlogs.
So, ähm,
Stripes,
Dankeschön für den Sub,
20 Monate,
massive subscription.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Leute, ich sage euch gleich,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
wie lange ich schon on bin.
Ich habe mir ein jubelndes Kopf
gesetzt seit zwei Tagen
und wenn ich mich hinlege,
ist es besser.
Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt.
Ich glaube, es liegt daran,
ich habe ja so meine Vermutung,
ich glaube, es liegt am Umbau
von meinem Server,
weil ich bin da teilweise
so ungelenkig ja mittlerweile,
ja, und ich bin da teilweise
über Stunden auf der Erde rumgekrochen,
habe irgendwelche Dinger verlegt,
Sachen an die Wand geschraubt
und habe schräg um die Ecke geguckt
für 20 Minuten.
Ähm, genau,
eher Wub-Old als Wub-Corona, ja.
Und der 3D-Drucker steht ja auch drin,
vielleicht hat das auch
irgendwelche Ausdünstungen oder so.
Nee, aber ich glaube,
das liegt daran,
das heißt, wenn ich jetzt zu lange
vor dem Rechner sitze,
kriege ich Kopfweh.
Ich merke es permanent immer so ein bisschen,
aber wenn ich zu lange
vor dem Rechner sitze.
Es könnte natürlich auch 5G sein.
Was meint ihr, Leute?
Liegt es daran,
dass ich mich doof bewegt habe
oder meint ihr, es liegt an 5G?
Was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Ah, dachte ich mir, dachte ich mir.
Dachte ich, es muss 5G sein.
Ich glaube, wir haben hier
noch nicht mal 5G-Empfang.
Aber es ist schon 5G.
Es liegt an der Impfung.
Ich bin nicht dick genug.
Ich kriege keine Impfung.
Leute, ich bin nicht.
Ich bin nicht Pepo fett genug.
Man kriegt ab einem BMI von 40
kriegt man, kriegt man die Impfung
wie, glaube ich, ab 70-Jährige.
Es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten.
Entweder ich dem Ultraschnell sehr viel zu,
dass ich über ein BMI über 40 komme,
oder ich lasse mich erst impfen,
wenn ich noch mal dran komme.
Ich fürchte, auf Dauer gesünder ist,
nicht zuzunehmen.
Ich hatte eh letztens schon ein Problem.
Ich habe letztens zwei Burger-Menüs bestellt,
Mittagessen.
Und dann ruft der Typ an vom Lieferdienst
und meint, er kommt später.
Er verspätet sich irgendwie ein paar Minuten.
Na ja, okay, was soll ich machen?
Ich warte halt.
Dann kommt er an und sagt, ja,
als Entschuldigung hat er drei Burger-Menüs mitgebracht.
Also ich habe die zwei auch schon nicht alleine gegessen.
Ja.
Er hat drei Burger-Menüs.
Ich musste dann letztens quasi eineinhalb
oder sagen wir mal eher zwei Burger-Menüs futtern.
Wegen mir kann er gerne immer zu spät kommen,
wenn es dann eins umsonst gibt.
Aber ich habe schon mal den Weg da geebnet.
Ja.
Lässt du dich impfen?
Wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Übrigens hier zu diesem Impfthema.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich dazu ein Video aufnehmen soll.
Aber das ist ja so ein.
Etwas Sekunde.
Warte mal.
Hä, was der Fack?
Was immer im zweiten Monitor.
Ah, das ist Avira 0 W.
Das ist Avira.
Avira ist der Meinung, ich bin super ungeschützt, weil ich Avira nicht gekauft habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich den Scheiß überhaupt noch installiert habe.
Übrigens.
Also ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich zu diesem Thema ein Video ein Video aufnehmen soll.
Und zwar.
Ähm.
Äh.
Also ich nehme dazu kein Video auf, weil wenn die Leute das im Titel schon sehen, da sind sie ja wieder getriggert.
Aber was ich eigentlich, ähm, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte in dem Video, das kann ich jetzt ja mal hier, kann ich jetzt mal hier im Stream sagen.
Ich wollte mich gar nicht über irgendwie impfen oder nicht impfen oder sowas auslassen.
Ich wollte mich darüber auslassen, warum ich denke, dass unsere Regierung oder generell so viel in verantwortlichen Positionen selbst daran schuld sind, dass so viele Menschen, die sich nicht impfen, nicht impfen.
Oder wenn sie dann das sagen, dass sie sich nicht impfen möchten und die Leute teilweise, die sich zurücklegen wollen, auch mit dran schuld sind.
Oder teilweise zumindest.
Zumindest mit dran schuld.
Weil es wurde so viel Vertrauen verspielt, was glaubwürdigkeit angeht, wegen dieser ganzen Corona Geschichte, dass ich jetzt die Leute sogar teilweise verstehen kann, wenn sie komplett quasi, ähm.
Jolo mäßig oder so komplett ohne, ohne tieferen Sinn, eigentlich sagen.
Sie wollen sich nicht impfen lassen.
Kann ich nachvollziehen.
Man darf nicht vergessen.
Am Anfang wurde beispielsweise erzählt.
Ähm, Masken helfen nix, dann kam raus, ja doch, Masken helfen schon was, aber man hat es am Anfang gesagt, damit beispielsweise kein Engpass bei Masken entsteht.
Mag ein ehrenwertes Ziel sein, da sag ich gar nix dagegen, aber es schafft auf jeden Fall nicht das Vertrauen, also es stärkt nicht das Vertrauen in die Aussagen, die da getroffen werden.
Dann wurde beispielsweise gesagt, man macht diese personenbezogenen Daten, also sprich, dort wo man ausfüllen musste, ich hab irgendeinen Fussel am Mikro hängen, warte mal, dort wo man ausfüllen musste, beim Friseur war ich übrigens schon, letzten Donnerstag, genau, und dann gab es diese personenbezogenen Daten, wo man ausfüllen musste, wo man, oder sollte, wo man war.
Und da haben die Leute ja mitgemacht, unter anderem auch, weil gesagt wurde, diese Person...
Diese personenbezogenen Daten sind, also, ne, wo man sich aufgehalten hat, wo man zum Mittagessen war, sind rein zweckgebunden und werden für nichts anderes verwendet.
Zwei Wochen später oder so kam dann die bayerische Polizei und meinte, ach, nö, nö, wir nehmen die auch, wir greifen da auch drauf zu.
So schaffst du halt kein Vertrauen in deine Aussagen.
Und das ist das eigentliche Problem, was ich denke, was bei vielen der Fall ist, warum sie sagen, ich glaub keine mehr was, ich lass mich deswegen nicht impfen.
Ich glaub gar nicht immer so sehr, dass das daher kommt, dass die denken, dass sie irgendwie krank werden durch die Impfung oder so.
Einfach nur...
Ich glaub den Leuten aus Prinzip nix.
Und das haben die echt verschissen.
Du kannst nicht, du kannst nicht einfach, und es gibt ja noch viel mehr Beispiele, die jetzt nicht Corona-bezogen sind,
du kannst halt den Leuten nicht einfach öfters mal Scheiße erzählen und dann irgendwie hoffen, die Leute glauben dir noch.
Das klappt halt nicht, die waren halt nicht agil genug, ja.
Also das ist halt das Problem, was ich sehe dabei.
Ich glaub, vielen geht's gar nicht darum, ob das Impfzeug irgendwie schädlich ist.
Die sagen so, ich glaub euch aus Prinzip nix mehr.
Ja, das ist normal bei Alstrike.
Hab ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen?
Ja, das Stripes, dankeschön, wie gesagt.
Exquisite Hyper-Subscription, 20 Monate.
Ja, und da wollte ich eigentlich ein Video...
Oh, hier, Tribolon, dankeschön, 16 Monate Hyper-Subscription.
Die brauchen Agile, hab ich mir sagen lassen, spricht er sich ja aus.
Agile.
Ich hab übrigens, wo wir grad bei Agile und Poggers sind,
ich hab mir ein Netzteil gekauft von, bei Amazon, Top Charger.
Top Charger, keine Ahnung, wie man das ausspricht.
Das ist ein Netzteil.
Top Charger, kommt aus Frankreich.
Top Charger.
Wie spricht man das aus?
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie, ich dachte eigentlich ursprünglich,
das ist ein China-Netzteil, weil die Chinesen-Shops,
die haben ja immer so Namen, das ist so ein bisschen familiär,
oder bekannt klingen soll, aber nein, das waren wirklich Franzosen, ne?
Was machst du alles mit Copernetis?
Daheim gar nix?
Auf der Arbeit haben wir ein paar, mir fällt schwer, das Microservices zu nennen,
ein paar umgewurstelte Nicht-so-Microservices in Copernetis,
die aber deswegen noch drei Spiele an Abhängigkeiten für den Container brauchen,
weil sie halt nicht so micro sind.
Macht sich cool, ja.
Wie gesagt, lass ich.
Bist du ein Docker-Fan?
Ich benutze Docker, ich weiß nicht, ob ich ein Docker-Fan bin.
Ich finde Docker gut.
Und so für den Desktop-Bereich eigentlich somit das Beste,
was man so nehmen kann.
Ich meine, es gibt noch ein paar Alternativen,
man kann aktuell Potman nehmen, man könnte auch
dieses klassische Container-Format sein lassen und LXD nehmen,
aber ich finde Docker an sich nicht schlecht,
gerade durch das große Ökosystem,
was es halt drumherum gibt.
Ja, nee, deswegen mache ich da kein Video zu.
Die Leute sind wieder...
Ja, genau.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem,
weil ich habe die Leute nur noch schwarz und weiß.
Es gibt ja auch noch ein bisschen was dazwischen
und es kann durchaus andere Gründe haben,
außer dass man ein Verschwörungstheoretiker ist,
weil man irgendwas nicht will.
Oder wenn man was will, kann es auch andere Gründe haben,
dass man ein, wie sagen sie immer,
äh, versiffter Gutmensch, was auch immer ist.
Es gibt ja eigentlich...
Also, in der Regel liegt die Wahrheit immer irgendwo dazwischen
und das ist das, was viele aktuell vergessen.
Ja, denn die Corona-Videos, die sind ja sogar abgeschaltet,
die Comments.
Guck mal hier.
Äh...
Ich habe doch irgendwo ein Corona-Video offen.
Der Aldi, der Aldi-Test.
Guck mal.
Aldi-Test, wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Oh, nee.
Oh, wow.
Die haben...
Oh, das hätte ich gar nicht gehört.
Die haben die Kommentare an.
Selten, selten.
Normalerweise sind die Comments immer aus.
Ja, das ist doch nice.
Was ich halt dann auch wiederum nicht gut finde, ist...
Also, wie gesagt, ich lasse mich impfen.
Aber was ich dann auch wiederum nicht so gut finde, ist,
wenn man dann anfängt mit, ähm...
Du musst jetzt quasi belegen, dass du geimpft bist,
dass du manche Sachen machen darfst.
So sollte das nicht sein, ja?
Also, du solltest quasi...
deine Freiheit ausüben können,
ohne dass du beweisen musst, dass du frei sein darfst.
Das finde ich nicht so sinnvoll.
Ja.
Aber ich lasse mich auf jeden Fall impfen.
Ich lasse mich auf jeden Fall impfen, wenn es soweit ist.
Übrigens, hier diese...
Habt ihr diese Diskussion um diese QR-Code-App...
Wie heißt das?
App mitgekriegt?
Äh, Kontaktverfolgungs-App,
die angeblich Smudo mitprogrammiert hat?
Vielleicht wart ihr auch so verwirrt wie ich,
was Smudo damit zu tun hat.
Aber der Typ hat früher angeblich wirklich auf dem C64 Spiele programmiert.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Gut, der wird wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich großartig was drin mitentwickelt haben.
Aber...
Aber wisst ihr, was ich mich dabei frage?
Und das konnten mir noch keine erklären.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kann das...
Oh, Chat, ich muss euch übrigens gleich da noch was anderes fragen.
Es konnten mir noch keiner...
Nicht Sudo, Smudo.
Sudo.
Na, wenn es Sudo wäre, wäre das einfach.
Da müssten sich alle interessieren.
So, also, was mir da noch keiner erklären konnte,
was ich nicht so genau verstanden habe, ist,
warum kann man das nicht in die Corona-App einbauen?
Jetzt ernst, ich verstehe es nicht.
Weil, ich weiß nicht, warum.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
So was lebt doch damit,
dass das viele Leute installiert haben.
Wenn das nur 20 Leute installiert haben,
bringt das doch nichts.
So, und die Corona-App haben ja nun schon
mittlerweile viele, viele, ähm...
installiert. Das heißt, man hätte
eine relativ...
relativ große Installationsbasis.
Das heißt,
ich verstehe nicht, warum kann man das
nicht in die Corona-App einbauen?
Zumal,
zumal man ja echt sagen muss,
GPS-Tracking.
GPS-Tracking ist
easy as fuck einzubauen.
Das baue ich, das baue ich in, in zwei Stunden ein.
Jetzt ohne Scheiß, das ist nicht schwer.
Ich habe das sogar schon mal testweise gemacht.
Mit einer, also, mit einer PWA,
mit einer Web-App.
Aber GPS-Tracking ist wirklich
total einfach.
Auch Background-Tracking, das ist total einfach.
Also, das könnte man ohne Probleme
in die Corona-App einbauen und
ich weiß, dass das hier nicht,
dass das hier irgendwas proprietäres ist
und die einen wollen was Offenes und sonst was.
Aber man könnte doch einfach zwei Fliegen
mit einer Klappe erschlagen.
Man macht es in die Corona-App ein.
Du kannst das an- oder ausschalten.
Du musst ja eh der App
GPS-Berechtigung geben oder nicht.
Das kann ja eine App gar nicht so.
Also, die App fragt einfach,
die sagt einfach,
Request Permission, GPS,
Background, so.
Und entweder sagst du ja oder nee.
Wenn du sagst nee in dem Berechtigungsdialog,
dann macht die halt nach wie vor
Bluetooth-Tracking und gut ist,
wenn du sagst ja, dann kannst,
dann kannst dich tracken, so.
Und das Zweite ist ja, was diese andere App
irgendwie kann, ist, du kannst QR-Codes scannen.
Apple und Google erlauben keinen Zugriff
auf GPS, wenn du das Covid-Tracing
Hä? Wie?
Ich kann von einer x-beliebigen Webseite auf GPS
zugreifen, warum soll ich das nicht aus der Corona-App
machen können? Stehe ich nicht.
Und im Zweifelsfall kann man, könnte man sich da sicherlich
als, sagen wir mal so, Regierung
irgendwas bewirken. Das Nächste ist
die Sache mit dem QR-Code.
GPS-Tracking funktioniert halt nicht mehr so gut.
Hä? Na klar!
Du kannst dich subscriben zum GPS-Tracking,
zu, zu, ähm,
du kannst die Location-Tracking-API
subscriben und dann wirst du
alle Major,
Major Location-Changes oder
glaube ich alle zwei Minuten mal kurz aufgeweckt.
Deine App. Und kann das
machen. Ja? Also das,
das wären ja zwei Funktionen in einer App, die miteinander
nichts zu tun haben. Also man könnte da garantiert was machen.
Zumindest konnte mir noch keiner schlüssig
erklären. Es gibt nur so Vermutungen, wie so
ah, das geht nicht und sonst was. Ich hab die Vermutung,
das liegt gar nicht an technischen Gründen.
Und das Nächste ist, diese QR-Code-Geschichte,
das könnte man doch da auch
easy einbauen.
Nee, das machen alle
möglichen, äh, was meinst du
wie das Google Maps macht?
Oder, oder Apple Maps?
Oder, oder, äh,
Live360 oder
was auch immer. Nein, es gibt keine Gründe.
Du kannst ja zustimmen oder abschließen.
Oder ablehnen. So, also wie gesagt, das
GPS-Tracking ist einfach einzubauen.
Das hab ich sogar selbst schon mal gemacht.
Die Sache ist nur die,
ähm,
das Problem ist nur die,
GPS-Tracking alleine,
das bringt dir nix.
Was eine App des
Bluetooth-Tracking benutzt, was extra für Corona
gebaut wird, kein Zugriff auf GPS-Anfragen,
da kann man garantiert irgendwas machen.
So, und, ähm,
so, und diese QR, diese,
wie willst du denn sonst Location-Tracking
machen ohne GPS? So, und diese
ganze Sache mit den QR-Codes, ich weiß nicht,
ob das auch hier drin steht. Es geht ja auch, dass du QR-Codes
QR-Codes, äh, scannst, wo du bist und so was.
Das kann man doch auch alles einbauen.
Also, ich versteh nicht, warum die Leute sich noch
einen zweiten, noch eine zweite App installieren sollen,
was sie auch garantiert nicht machen werden und es wieder im Sande verlaufen wird.
Warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, ey,
wir haben ne offizielle App, die hat ne gewisse
Reichweite, wir bauen die einfach aus.
Ich, es leuchtet mir, leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Und selbst wenn GPS
nicht geht,
weil, äh, das irgendwelche Google-Limitierungen
oder Apple-Limitierungen gibt, dann kann man zumindest diese
QR-Code-Geschichte einbauen.
Ja, man könnte,
ja, bei Stripe, man könnte das auch noch einbauen.
Weil, wenn ich,
wenn ich eine, eine,
ähm, so ne, so ne, so ne,
wo, wo, wo bin ich
gewesen, App entwickeln
würde, das würd ich, das würd ich über drei verschiedene
Sachen machen. Das würd ich einmal gucken, dass ich vielleicht
Bluetooth irgendwie gucke, was um mich drum herum ist.
Irgendwelche Beacons oder sonst wie.
Dann würd ich gucken, was für offene WLANs gibt's
und sonstige Geschichten. Ich würd GPS machen.
Und, ähm,
ich würd Sachen zum Scannen und manuell
Eintragen anbieten, wenn das nicht stimmt, was da drin
steht. So. Und mit GPS hast du den großen
Vorteil, ähm,
du kannst auch Reverse-Lookup
machen. Also sprich, wenn du grad keine Ahnung
hast, wo du bist, aber beispielsweise
du sitzt auf ner offenen Fläche, wo alle am Eis
futtern sind, sagst du, ah, okay, vielleicht sollte
ich besser mal das, äh,
tracken lassen, dass ich hier jetzt irgendwie mit, äh,
20 Leuten gesessen hab, äh, irgendwie
im Park Eis gegessen hab. So.
Dann machst du die App auf, also so würd ich das machen.
Machst du die App auf, okay,
äh, hier gibt's keinen QR-Code zum Scannen,
ich drück auf den Tracking-Knopf,
das Ding macht ein GPS, äh, guckt
GPS, macht ein Reverse, äh,
Geo-Geo-Coding, guckt, wo ich bin auf der
Karte, schlägt mir das nächstgelegene
vor, was halt eben irgendeine, äh,
Geo-Code-AP ausspuckt,
dann krieg ich ein vorausgefülltes Ding,
so nach dem Motto, das sind die Sachen, die wir jetzt übermitteln.
Und da kann ich noch korrigieren,
so nach dem Motto, ich bin, äh,
nicht Haus Nummer 31 oder Haus
Nummer 35, keine Ahnung, das schick ich ab.
Das wär das einfachste, das wär das einfachste
für die Leute, da kann man's nämlich auch manuell erfassen.
Also, wie
gesagt, das leuchtet, leuchtet mir nicht so genau ein.
Moin, Leko.
Ja, na, einfach, einfach,
ganz ehrlich, wegen mir können die Home-Office-
Geschichte auch noch viel, viel, ähm,
ähm, mit der Reverso
gibt's schon Metadatenpreis, ja und?
Heh, das mach ich doch bei 30 Milliarden
anderen Diensten auch.
Außerdem kann ich ja zustimmen, oder
ablehnen vorher, wenn ich zustimme, muss ich
mich danach nicht beschweren, dass ich Datenpreis gebe,
weil ich hab ja zugestimmt.
Ähm, wenn ich nicht
zustimme, muss ich mir keine Gedanken machen, dass das Ding
Zugriff drauf hat.
Hast du das mit den Windows-Lizenzen mitbekommen? Nee, was denn?
Erzähl. Hab ich nicht mitgekommen?
Ja, das dauert ewig.
Das dauert ewig.
Ja, ohne Center of Excellence geht
nix. Hast du Empfehlungen
für Ein-U-Netzteile?
Nee, aber weißt du, wie ich das bei meinem
System gemacht hab?
Ich hab ja hier in
Wobei, ich zeig's dir mal auf Twitter.
Ich hab ja hier
Hab ich das Bild?
Hier, hier unten in dieser 2-HE-Kiste,
ne, da ist
gar kein richtiges Netzteil drinne.
Da ist so ein Netzteil drinne.
Sowas da in der Richtung.
Liegt da einfach im Gehäuse drin und hinten
kommt der Stecker raus, auf so einem freien
Slot.
Da ist gar kein richtiges
Netzteil drinne in der Kiste.
Einfach das Ding ins Gehäuse
gelegt, Kabel rausgemacht.
Äh, ich hab mal ne Frage.
Bald steht Online-Prüfung an über Moodle.
Okay. Warum hab ich eigentlich immer noch den Franzose eingeblendet?
So.
Äh.
Was? Moment. Ich hab ne Frage.
Bald steht Online-Prüfung an über...
Wir würden dir gerne zusammen...
Hehe. Also du möchtest
bescheißen quasi auf gut Deutsch.
Seh ich das richtig, ja?
Äh.
Nein. Also wenn
du das nicht übern Browser machst, kannst du das nicht
erkennen.
Die Webseite kann das nicht erkennen.
Mir fällt zumindest nichts ein,
wie die das erkennen können. Und wenn du auf...
Ohne Scheiß, wenn du auf ganz Nummer
sicher gehen willst, dass man das definitiv
niemals erkennen kann, ist
Capture Card, zweiter Rechner.
Dann erkennt
niemand jemals irgendwas.
Nummer sicher, Webcam auf Bildschirm
richten. Ja, das geht auch, aber das sieht scheiße aus.
Twitch Mason,
Prime Gaming, 10 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Aber ich würd's
nicht machen, ja? Wie gesagt,
seh ich auch so. Ich würd's nicht machen.
Wenn sie euch nämlich erwischen, ist die Prüfung wahrscheinlich
instant ungültig und du bist, äh...
gefickt.
Also ich würd's nicht
machen, aber machbar ist es.
Äh...
Monschru
CX, die E-Grills,
die filmen ja auch sich und nicht ihren
Bildschirm.
Das ist ja wieder was anderes.
Falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, sag Bescheid.
Spread the Beast,
17 Monate Hyper-Subscription
hier am Start. Massive.
Wo hab ich meine Hyper-Subscription?
Ja, das ist natürlich
auch ne Sache. Ähm...
Wenn das was ist, wo man
wirklich Text eintragen muss, ja?
Und alle schreiben die gleichen Sätze rein.
Dann merkt man das. Hups, fuck.
Nein, ich hab den Chat zu... Aber ich hab den Chat
ja zum Glück noch auf nem anderen Bildschirm. Lull.
Ähm... Dann merkt man das.
Ja? Aber halt nicht daran, dass ihr den Bildschirm
geshared habt, sondern weil man's anderweitig
merkt. Äh...
Ich hab zu weit hochgescrollt.
Ich hab nix übersehen, oder?
Kann das sein?
Muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Abos übersehen hab.
Übrigens, Microsoft hat das gleiche
Problem bei ihren, äh,
Zertifikaten. Und die haben da ganz
ganz strikte Regelungen. Also,
du wirst beobachtet, genau.
Du wirst beobachtet, während du die
Prüfung machst. Du musst vorher mit der Kamera
deinen Raum zeigen. Du musst die
Tür geschlossen haben. Du darfst nicht reden
während der Prüfung. Es darf nichts
sichtbar sein, außer du und
deine Tastatur auf der Kamera
während die gesamte Prüfung.
Also die sind da bei ihren Zertifikaten wirklich
hardcore drauf.
Ist jetzt kein Witz, das machen die wirklich.
Natürlich gibt's
Sachen, wo das nicht so ist. Aber wie gesagt, Microsoft ist
da sehr pingelig bei beispielsweise
ihren Azure Zertifikaten und sowas.
Ja.
So. Gucken wir mal
was. Mit was, mit was, mit was
fangen wir denn an?
Mit was, mit was, mit was fangen wir an?
Okay, wir gucken uns, wir gucken
uns jetzt mal das, wir gucken uns mal das
Level Cap Video an, weil ich weiß,
dass ich das zwei Minuten gucken werde und
danach ausschalte und mir sage
wieder, warum hast du das geguckt? Der Typ
erzählt eh 0815 Zeug,
die es, also in letzter Zeit, die es nicht wert sind
ein Video drüber zu machen.
Aber,
mach trotzdem Videos drüber.
So, mal gucken, ob wir wieder jebaited werden.
Ein Bold Move
haben sie gemacht.
Was könnte, okay, okay,
was könnte ein mutiger Schritt von
EA sein, was Battlefield angeht?
Ähm,
auf die Spieler hören vielleicht.
Aber das macht man wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Äh, Stripes 007, ja gut.
Du kannst da aber auch trotzdem
so ein Netzteil reinstecken, wie ich gezeigt
habe und das Kabel raus machen.
Okay, okay, wenn das EA selbst sagt,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich alles andere als Bold,
weil EA nur das macht,
was stonkisch ist.
Fällt mir im Prinzip ganz gut. Stonkisch
passt sehr gut ins Wort.
Also,
ich mein, wenn das ernsthaft Ende des Jahres
kommen sollte, ein paar spielbare
Alphas sollten sie
durchaus schon haben.
Kein komplettes Produkt, aber zumindest
teilweise
spielbare Sachen.
Okay, bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla.
Who cares?
I know.
Ist mir sowas von scheiß egal,
ob die Need for Speed.
Was? Was? Aber warum?
Aber ich mein,
jetzt mal ernsthaft,
viel hilft
nicht immer vielen, ja?
Also sprich,
die können ja schlecht
5000 Leute an Battlefield setzen
und meinen, das wird dann ein besseres Game.
Oh nee.
Ja.
Wundert mich nicht, dass die das sagen.
Und es wäre ja auch
merkwürdig, wenn der
Ankündigungstrailer noch nicht
in Production wäre, weil
wenn das wirklich Ende des Jahres rauskommt
dann müssen die ja langsam mal was ankündigen.
Oder teasen.
Alter, was ist das für
Huge Aim gewesen gerade wieder.
so I'll believe it when I see it.
One thing that should give players hope for Battlefield 6
is that EA gave DICE an extra year
to work on it. Rumors and estimates
put Battlefield 5's total development time
around 18 months, which is an absurdly
short amount of time for a game that big.
Battlefield 6 getting at least two years
of active development can only mean good
things. Just don't base your expectations
on what EA or anyone else says.
Ja, korrekt. Aber
deswegen, das ist so geil,
das ist so geil, was für eine
geile Aussage, so nach dem Motto, gebt
nix drauf, was EA sagt, aber ich
mach erstmal ein Video über alles das, was EA
gesagt hat. Wobei auf der anderen Seite
kann ich das ja nicht mal verwerflich finden, das würde
ich wahrscheinlich auch machen, wenn es irgendwas Interessantes wäre,
was sie gesagt hätten.
Es ist absolut
unrealistisch, überhaupt was zu dem Game
zu sagen. Man hatte noch nicht mal
ingame, nicht mal
ingame,
league-Builder oder so gesehen,
gar nix.
Ah, okay.
Okay, easy, easy,
das war's, das war's.
So, da können wir uns, machen wir gleich weiter,
komm, wir gucken uns jetzt Battlefield, Battlefield
4 Top Plays an, wenn wir gerade schon mal
Battlefield waren, fangen wir damit an.
Oh, guck mal, hat Logitech
sehr laut jetzt.
Alter, was hat der Typ für ein Bass-Setting?
Aber,
der hört nur noch Bass, der Typ, oder?
Gatschi-Bass.
Ich lass das absichtlich leiser,
ähm,
weil ich laber ja eh immer drüber.
Wo ist dein Hetzer sehr laut? Ich hab mit Hetzer
noch nix zu tun gehabt.
Also mit der Marketingabteilung.
Ja, das ist immer so, die Gegner schießen
nicht zurück.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Oh!
Nice!
Ich frag mich nur gerade, was machen die da eigentlich
alle auf dem Dach?
Das sind bestimmt 20 Sniper,
die nicht wissen, was sie machen sollen
und deswegen auf dem Haus campen und runtersnipen.
Was machen die Dudes da oben alle?
Corona-Party.
Also, man muss viel machen.
Das ist ein wunderbarer Tag.
Na, wirklich?
Du könntest doch Hetzer-Affiliate machen.
Ne, also, irgendein Affiliate-Programm mach ich nicht.
Suck Gaming.
Excellent.
Wenn schon, ähm, wenn schon,
muss ich mich mit denen mal direkt da kurz schließen,
was man da sehr lautmäßig machen könnte.
Ich kann, wie gesagt, auf YouTube, auf Twitch,
könnt man das ja alles gut platzieren.
Das wär ja auch ein Serveranbieter,
wo ich selbst mal n Kram hab.
Ich weiß, dass die was taugen.
Ähm,
dann müsste ich mit denen mal in touch gehen, ja?
Aber hab ich grad keinen Bock.
Ich bin auch kein Fan von MySpace,
ich werde ja nicht so lange in die TV gehen müssen.
gehen, ja? Aber habe ich gerade keinen Bock mich drum zu kümmern.
Helder, Shotgun Clips!
Ich dachte er messet ihn jetzt, aber das wäre eine blöde Idee gewesen mit
3 Milliarden Gegnern drumherum.
Gegner, ihr dürft auch zurückballern, ja? Das ist erlaubt.
War das in Battlefield 4 nicht so, dass...
Ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
In Battlefield 3 hat Suppression dafür gesorgt, dass du nichts mehr triffst.
In Battlefield 4 war Suppression nur noch optisch, außer bei LMGs, oder?
Oder auch bei LMGs nur noch optisch?
Da darf er BIG ab, innermals.
BackRage.
Ein verliebter BackRage.
Ach, was ist das für ein Ding? Das Ding habe ich noch nie gespielt...
Das habe ich noch nie gespielt, das Ding.
Wann schickst du deine Clips ein? Wenn ich nicht so faul wäre, hätte ich schon
längst eingeschickt. Oh Leute, es ist auf der falschen Seite. So, hier ist besser.
Ich muss sieg im Hintergrund. Aber echt, nicer Clip. Krass gebasht werden sie.
By the way, ich habe das Salami-Emote konserviert. Fällt euch das auf? Das ist
überall gelöscht mittlerweile. Ich hab's noch. Twitch, Twitch, first only Salami.
Nicht first, last. Twitch last Salami.
Warum ist die weg? Weil die gesagt haben, sie wollen keine
anstößigen Emotes haben.
Aha, sellout.
Also, Logitech ist auch was, wo ich mich sponsern lassen würde. Das ist auch, ich
benutze schon lange Logitech-Sachen, finde die eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Einzige, wo ich so ein bisschen für geflamed habe, ist meine letzte Tastatur,
wo die, wo die Control-Taste einfach abgebrochen ist.
Ja, und wäre
als Sponsor, würde ich auch sofort nehmen.
Wenn du findest, Logitech hat's ja abgenommen. Okay, warum?
But why? Also, ich muss sagen, mit der letzten Tastatur war ich auch nicht zufrieden, wo die
Control-Taste abgebrochen ist. Also, ich muss sagen, mit der letzten Tastatur war ich auch nicht zufrieden, wo die Control-Taste abgebrochen ist.
Aber immer noch besser als die Corsar-Tastatur mit doppelten Tastenanschlägen.
Wenigstens ging die, ging und geht die Logitech-Tastatur noch. Außer die Control-Taste.
Ja, Numplock muss sein.
Wobei meine Lieblingstastatur, wisst ihr, was meine Lieblingstastatur ist, ernsthaft?
Also, nicht für daheim, nicht für Spiele und Makros, aber meine Lieblingstastatur so generell zum benutzen.
Ups.
Äh, die da.
Aber mit Numplock, die da.
Beste.
Ich, zum Spielen weiß ich nicht, ob ich sie der anderen vorziehen würde.
Und man kann auch, das hat auch keine Makro-Software dabei, was auch ein bisschen doof ist.
Ich will, so ein paar Kleinigkeiten mache ich gerne mit Makros, zum Beispiel Desktop-Switchen und sowas.
Aber rein zum Tippen und zum Arbeiten ist das meine absolute Lieblingstastatur.
Übrigens, das ist meine Lieblingstastatur.
Übrigens, die meine ich nicht.
Äh, ich habe eine mit komplett hohem Enter.
Nicht so ein Crap da.
Mit Numplock, mit Numplock und mit Enter.
So eine da.
Mit Numplock und Enter.
Nicht so.
Was ist das für ein Crap?
Sowas da.
Genau.
Das da.
Beste.
Und Numplock.
Daniel Ludl, 20 Monate.
Oh, massive Subscriptions hier wieder.
Nice, danke für die Subs.
Also wie gesagt, das ist meine Lieblingstastatur.
So.
Und sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Äh, da.
Wie gesagt, jetzt wo diese viele Leute da sind, ich habe seit ein paar Tagen übelst Kopfweh.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich am Start bin heute.
Aber aktuell, aktuell geht's.
Und der Chat ist sich sicher, es liegt an 5G.
Und dann ein 44 Magnum.
Und es gibt noch ein paar Tötungen in der Nähe.
Auf dieser Wave von Spielern.
Wie lange bin ich noch wach?
Torturer of Souls ist nächstes.
Torturer of Souls.
Wisst ihr was?
Das ist ein Name.
Den kann nur jemand haben, der älter ist.
Das ist so ein typischer, das ist so ein typischer Emo-Name.
Gibt's ja heute nicht mehr.
Wurdest du geimpft?
Nee, ich bin nicht dick genug.
Ich darf noch nicht.
Ich darf jetzt erst, ich darf jetzt erst dann, wenn alle anderen auch dürfen.
Ab einem BMI von 40, da darf man ja auch vorher.
Genau, das ist so ein typischer Emo-Name.
Die sind, die gibt's ja auch nicht mehr, ne?
Keine Emos mehr.
Guckt mal in die, guckt mal, guckt mal rum.
Okay, aktuell eh nicht.
Aber guckt mal, es gibt kaum noch welche mehr.
Kaum noch mehr mit irgendwelchen dunklen Dingern an.
Geschminkt und Augenring und alles.
Es gibt, und diese komischen Rucksäcke mit Anhänger.
Und sowas.
Es gibt keine Emos mehr.
Wo sind die alle hin?
Aber der war bestimmt mal einer, Torturer of Souls.
Der Name ist so Emo-mäßig.
Meinst du Corona ist daran schuld?
Nee, die waren vorher auch schon weg.
Die, die waren, die waren vorher auch schon weg.
Ja.
Ich hab ja früher auch so ein bisschen so Emo-Musik gehört.
Sowas in der Richtung.
So, aber eher, eher Richtung Metal-Sachen.
Das war einfach, das war einfach andere, andere Zeit.
Okay, das hat aber nicht so gut funktioniert.
Oh, nice, nice.
Headshot scoped.
Warum haben die ganzen Schneider-Dudes eigentlich in Battlefield Laser?
Ist das weniger Bullet-Drop oder, oder, oder was?
Kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern, wie das ist bei Battlefield 4.
Oder sieht man es einfach besser?
Bessere No-Scopes aus der Hüfte?
Now for another Locker-Clip, and we will see quite a few Locker-Clips in today's episode,
with it being a Rambo-Special.
This one from Breast is a little bit more slow and calculated,
as you often see from his clips,
but the accuracy is up there with the very best.
Dominating the tower here on Charlie objective,
he's stopping the enemies pushing in,
putting together a Rambo 4.
ACE-23.
Ding war POC.
Really nice, accurate street.
Oder ACE.
Ich weiß nicht.
Leute, wie, wie spricht man da?
Wie spricht man das eher aus?
ACE oder ACE?
Ich denke mal, das ist eine Abkürzung.
Arche?
Ja, das wird es sein.
ACE, das ist so ein, das ist so ein, so ein Multivitamin-Saft.
Genau!
Killrock, genau das wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Das ist so ein Multivitamin-Saft.
Ja, Leko, das hat der, hat der Sebaru mal ausprobiert und fand es ganz toll.
Ich mag eher mein eigenes, selbstkonfiguriertes E3.
Das ist ein E4, der auf der Lankan Dam spielt.
Mit der ACE 23 ist es eine großartige, versatiler Waffe in der Medikation.
Wenn du eine Waffe suchst, die nur ein bisschen mehr hat,
in Bezug auf die Magazin, das ist eine F dazwischen.
Aber immer noch super einfach zu verwenden,
kraftvoll, präzise, einfach eine einfache Waffe,
denke ich, für die meisten Menschen, die es benutzen,
wenn du dich an diesen AEK mühsam findest.
Das ist ein objective Spieler, der auch wieder Gegner ist,
der nicht zurückschießt.
Alter, was hat der für eine Sense, der Dude? What the fuck?
Cool ist das, man. Der bewegt die Maus und... Oh, was ist das? Wusstet ihr, dass man das im
Vollbild einblenden kann? Ist mir neu. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht. Wie blendet
man das jetzt ein? Ah, da kann man ziehen. Das ist mir neu, das habe ich gerade
aus Versehen rausbekommen beim wild Maus rumwackeln. Das mit Scrollen kenne ich.
Und, und Vorwärts- und Rückwärtsspulen kenne ich mittlerweile auch. Also,
frameweise. Pogu. Wie, warum ist Pogu weg? Aber ich, aber jetzt haben wir, in
in Pognito haben wir jetzt. Was? Was heißt hier less skillful? Das ist ja wohl
offensichtlichste, das offen-, also total offensichtlich absolutes Highskill
Gameplay.
Zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, neun, neun, zehn, neun, zehn, neun, zehn, neun, zehn,
zehn, neun, zehn, neun, zehn, neun, bastante.
Vor allem wie sie nicht raus laütfen laufen! Man kann auch mit Vim bei ein
Dings Videos pausieren und skippen... Äh, wie soll man, wie soll man das
machen? Also, H und L oder was? definite skull strike
Nur bei mir geht J und L, K geht bei mir nicht... H macht Pause...
ja, aber das sind keine.... dasIS 49-7.ș
Nur halbe Wim-Bindings.
Links und rechts in Wim.
Also JK
ist doch hoch und runter
und HL ist links und rechts.
Das ist Fake-Wim-Bindings.
Alter, wie die da weiterhin reinrennen!
Ich kriege Anfälle,
wenn ich sowas sehe.
Ist das nicht auffällig,
wenn schon 20 Leute vor dir
im C4 in die Luft gesprengt wurden?
Muss man da auch noch reinrennen?
Ähm, äh,
Forever Next, das gibt's schon.
Ist das Konsole?
Das ist Konsole, ja, okay, dann, dann.
Dann wundert mich ja
nix mehr.
Wer Empfehlung für Steckdose, die Strom messen kann?
Ja, ich hab ein paar da,
aber ich glaube, die kann man nicht mal flashen
und die gibt's auch nur noch, also die gibt's flashbar
und nicht mehr, oder ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung,
ob man die noch flashen kann, ich glaube eher nicht.
Also ich hab aktuell
an meinem 3D-Drucker gerade
den hier angeschlossen.
Das ist den, den wir übrigens geflasht haben
letztens zusammen im Stream, wo ihr gedacht habt,
ich brick mein Gerät.
Den da, 16.
Die da.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob man die noch flashen kann.
Keine Ahnung.
Muss man gucken, dass die ein bisschen billiger...
Wobei,
ein Vierer-Pack für 36 Euro ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Äh, was kann man gegen Spulenfiepen machen,
außer Strom ausschalten?
Da gibt es die große Geheimwaffe
aller Bastler.
Heißkleber.
Einfach in Heißkleber tränken
und, ähm,
dann Spulenfiept's nicht mehr.
Also es geht, also das funktioniert wirklich.
Ja, das Spulenfiepen kommt ja daher,
Moin Chainlord, das kommt ja daher,
dass, äh, das, das vibriert.
Und wenn du das in Heißkleber tränkst,
in Heißkleber, Heißkleberst,
dann wird das nix mehr.
Ob das jetzt so gut ist für Wärmeableitungen und so,
sei mal dahingestellt.
Ja.
Aber, wie gesagt, also die hab ich gerade,
aber ich hab mir die Dinger ja noch letztes Jahr gekauft.
Das ist übrigens die, ich glaube,
die haben wir auch mal im Stream geflasht.
So, zumindest,
die können das, in der richtigen Variante.
Die können, äh, Strom messen.
Ich versuch's euch mal zu zeigen,
für einen 3D-Drucker.
Warte, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 60.
Punkt, äh, ich glaube,
100,
was, 128?
Nee, ich glaub, 108
war's, oder? Guck mal,
da sieht man's. So, das ist die,
das ist die, die ich grad am 3D-Drucker dran hab.
Und, äh, wenn ich den 3D-Drucker
anschalte, ich schalte jetzt mal den 3D-Drucker an,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es im Hintergrund
hört, dass es jetzt piepst.
Habt ihr?
Ihr hört mal nicht, oder?
Du, du, du, du, du.
Ja, das ist zu leise, das ist ja auch hinter einer Tür.
Ist ja, ist ja auch, doch, hat man gehört?
Okay, nice. Das war, es ist bei mir
im Serverraum hinter, hinter, hinter der Tür gewesen.
Ähm,
also jetzt ist, wird, äh,
jetzt ist gerade
dieser 3D-Drucker hier,
hat sich eingeschaltet, ja.
Und, äh, der verbraucht gerade
10 Watt, was jetzt
nicht so viel ist, weil der ist ja
auch noch nicht warm.
Naja, da würd ich jetzt nicht so viel
drauf geben, was hier steht, ja.
Ähm, ähm.
So, und,
also, die können das,
wie das hieß, ja.
Ich kann ja mal was drucken.
Ich glaub, 105 ist man.
Wobei, ich kann einfach sagen,
Octo-Exquisite-Passwort,
kommt keiner drauf.
Hab ich nämlich erst letztens neu installiert,
den Octopi.
Ähm, wir, wir gucken mal wieder,
Energie, ähm, ähm, Alter.
Ähm.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
So kurz Musik,
dann machen.
Exzellent.
So, ähm, ich kann mich mal verbinden
zu meinem 3D-Drucker.
Und wir, wir drucken jetzt mal,
wir drucken jetzt mal irgendwas.
Ich könnte, ich könnte aber was
wirklich Sinnvolles drucken, Leute,
fällt mir gerade auf.
Ich könnte, ich könnte die Unterseite
hierfür nochmal drucken.
Moment, wo hab ich denn das,
wo hab ich denn das hier überhaupt her?
Äh, irgendwo Thingiverse,
aber ich weiß nicht mehr, wie's heißt.
Ah, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie's heißt bei Thingiverse.
Okay, dann druck ich das jetzt einfach mal.
So, das druckt nur 23 Minuten oder so.
Wobei, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich lass einfach, ich lass einfach
nur mal aufwärmen.
Ich lass einfach nur mal aufwärmen.
So, drucken.
Und jetzt, und jetzt wärmt der, und jetzt gucken wir uns mal
den Druckverbrauch an.
Monka Smoke.
Jetzt geht's rauf.
Der Kram wird halt heiß, ne?
Und das ist aktuell
nur das Bett. Wartet mal ab.
Wartet mal ab, bis der, die,
die düse auf heizt auf auf 200 grad aktuell heißt er nur das bett und braucht
223 war der 3d drucker was für ein drucker hast du das ist ein anycubic i3
mega es soll wir waren jetzt noch mal eine minute dann geht nämlich die
eigentliche heizung an und dann muss ich auch dann breche ich ab weil ich will
den kram gar nicht noch mal drucken was würde eine usv hast du gar keine
ich habe hier unten zwar eine trainer aber dies nicht angeschlossen weil die
batterie kaputt ist und ich will die nicht ich will die nicht mehr
anschließen die habe ich jetzt rein als beschwerung von dem rack drin ich will
ja auch gar nicht mehr anschließen weil es fällt alles aus wenn die batterie
ausfällt was hängen geblieben ist das ist noch offline usv also es ergibt
überhaupt keinen sinn also solange strom da ist und die batterie abkackt soll es
gefälligst weiter funktionieren so jetzt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt also
jetzt ist das bett gleich aufgeheizt jetzt mal gucken wie viele dann
brauchen
auch jetzt immer bei 212 212 watt ist ja gerade verbringbar der kann sogar
energie energieverbrauch zählen eigentlich nicht so zu sagen so auf
jetzt hochfahren die nozzle warm machen nicht nicht die die die dass das hitta
ding warm machen und dann mal gucken wie
wie viel er verbraucht bin ich mal gespannt habe ich selbst noch nicht
geguckt übrigens auch so eine sache ich kann jetzt hier den 3d drucker einfach
ausschalten extruder genau aber es würde ich nicht empfehlen ich würde sagen
nachdem man den druck cancelt sollte man immer noch mal kurz warten dass das der
luft weil wenn ich das einfach ausschalten dreht sich der lüfter nicht
mehr und es ist heiß also besser man schaltet aus und wartet fünf minuten
bevor man komplett strom ausmacht so auf fang an zu heizen 3d drucker let's go hattest du nicht mal mit 3d drucker zu heizen?
3d drucker let's go hattest du nicht mal mit 3d drucker zu heizen?
hattest du nicht mal mit über wale 2 do flash also ich habe kein video darüber
gemacht wir haben video darüber geguckt und ja ich weiß dass bei den neuen robo
rocks ist nicht mehr geht aber ich habe glück und mein staubsauger roboter ließ
sich noch flaschen sogar ich habe letztens abgegründet auf
die neueste version der kann dann so dinger machen jetzt wie verschiedene
verschiedene stockwerke und alles mögliche
und er
weil es immer wieder leute mit ich habe meinen staubsauger roboter ich habe
meinen staubsauger geflasht und als staubsauger hat jetzt im webinterface
s5 bzw s50 das ist der gleiche ok jetzt wird geheizt leute wie der braucht
weniger weniger als mit dem hg bated gg gg bated
der wechselt sich voll ab guck mal na gut was auch wie dem auch sei ich breche den druck jetzt an ich breche den druck jetzt an
ich breche den druck jetzt an ich breche den druck jetzt an
jetzt cancel ich breche das jetzt ab weil ich will ich will es ja überhaupt nicht
jetzt cancel ich breche das jetzt ab weil ich will ich will es ja überhaupt nicht drucken der heiz camp genau ich will es ja überhaupt
drucken der heiz camp genau ich will es ja überhaupt
drucken der heiz camp genau ich will es ja überhaupt nicht drucken soll ich war jetzt kurz bis es
nicht drucken soll ich war jetzt kurz bis es
nicht drucken soll ich war jetzt kurz bis es runter geht ist jetzt gucken wir weiter
runter geht ist jetzt gucken wir weiter
runter geht ist jetzt gucken wir weiter und da mache ich das wieder aus hallo ich
und da mache ich das wieder aus hallo ich
hab gecancelt du solltest jetzt eigentlich nicht weiter hoch gehen wie
wäre es mit ausgehen nicht dass er jetzt noch anfängt zu drucken stopp stopp die
webcam habe ich abgemacht ich kann gerade nicht gucken stopp
stellen soll dankeschön für den sub 13 monat hyper subscription stopp der will
ich jetzt das kann nicht sein das kann nicht sein
das glaube ich nicht okay jetzt hat er abgebrochen jetzt hat er abgebrochen das
das war ein wenig unrealistisch gerade hier ach nee das ist target temperature
das ist target temperature das ist die target temperature das ist die aktuelle
temperatur captain sieg als l10 monat dankeschön für
den sub
okay genug 3d so jetzt ist kalt genug jetzt kann ich hier hingehen und sagen
bam 3d drucker off bam hat ein bisschen gedauert okay was auch immer
nice so jetzt ist er wieder aus sehr schön okay guck mal weiter wir sind
glaube ich immer noch mal battlefield ein rechner der wo die grafikkarte fett
ballert läuft drüber ja ja klar aber ich finde 250 schon nicht ohne
also ist auf definitiv genug wenn man nicht zu guckt und was schief geht dass
das haus abfackeln kann und na gut ist es nichts gegen den heizlüfter mit 2000
watt oder gegen den herd mit fragt mich nicht wie viel
bam bam da werden sie durch den schmuck gebäscht richtig schmuck ok das übliche
das übliche die gegner sehen wieder nichts coole setup ja du musst du musst
dir das du müsstest das jetzt mal sehen jetzt ist mittlerweile noch besser jetzt
habe ich nämlich mittlerweile den kram ordentlich verkabelt und auch das ganze
3d drucker zeugs dahin gehängt schon
aber spielen die wird in battlefield 4 nur noch locker gespielt
ich hab doch ein server raum video gemacht vor fünf tagen oder so noch
eins da muss es erst wirklich komplett fertig sein
ich habe das gefühl der eck reload ist in battlefield 4 schneller als in
battlefield 3 kann das sein oder oder täuscht das weil der eck reload in
battlefield 3 nicht mehr funktioniert
tutorial 3 kommt mir so ultra extrem residency elementary langsam vor
lecce d Solích 15 monaten subscription mehr
das game teilt am start locker wer hätte das gedacht noch mal ein locker clip
감사합니다
oh ja mousecam in battlefield 4
4. Der will's aber
professionell jetzt echt wissen.
Oh, was ist jetzt los?
Huge, was nu passiert.
Liko hat
5 Abos
gegiftet. Sehe ich das richtig? Danke schon für die ganzen
Subs. Huge Subscriptions.
Wir hatten was gekriegt.
Zeig mal her.
Bei Bane, gelber
Nasenaffe.
Gigantic.
Cubes.
Und der Informatiker underscore.
Excellent, excellent.
Huge Subscriptions.
Scamtrain hatte ich gescamt.
Ja, wenigstens
habe ich von dem Scamtrain was.
Besser als Leute lassen sich
in der WhatsApp-Gruppe scammen.
Da habe ich nichts von.
Chat, ich muss euch nach.
Ich muss euch nach.
Ich muss euch nach dem Battlefield-Video was Wichtiges
fragen.
Und nicht, ob ihr in meine WhatsApp-Gruppe kommt.
Letztens,
letztens, wurde mir ein Video
vom Klassiker schlechthin empfohlen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum mir
KLS-Videos empfohlen werden. Keine Ahnung.
Also,
der Kerl ist komplettes, nur noch
Meme mittlerweile, oder?
Also, er selbst
nimmt es ja noch übelst ernst, aber die Kommentare
haben ja absolut nichts mehr damit
zu tun. Früher wurden, früher
wurde das ja immer voll gefeiert,
ja? So die Leute, so nach dem Motto
Oh ja, geil, da zeigt uns, wie das krasse
Business geht. Und heute machen die sich alle
lustig in den Kommentaren drüber.
Und die Videos, die Videos
sind so auf dem Niveau von
Teleshopping früher.
Von irgendwelchen Teleshopping-Verkaufsveranstaltungen.
Ich, ich, verdient
der wirklich damit Geld?
Ich meine, muss er ja
sonst, okay, vielleicht pfeift er auch auf dem
letzten Loch, keine Ahnung. Ich habe schon lange kein
krasser Lifestyle am Strand mehr gesehen.
Aber,
das wirkt wie billiges Teleshopping.
Alter, guck mal hier,
wenigstens mal ein Battlefield-Spieler mit
fast CS-Sense.
Ja, wenigstens mal, wenigstens mal das gesamte
Mauspad für eine halbe Drehung, so muss das
sein.
Kann nicht sein, dass man aus dem
Handgelenk
aimt.
Warum hat er die Maus so weit hinten? Naja, dass sein Arm
aufliegt. Sonst, entweder bräuchte er
eine Armauflage,
die dann so kurz ist,
so eng, oder er müsste
die ganze Zeit sein Arm in der Luft halten.
Das kann ich schon verstehen.
Ich bin ja kein Arm-Aimer.
Ich mache so ein Zwischending.
Ich Handgelenk-Aime und wenn es
gar so schnell,
gewisse Distanz und schnell ist,
dann noch ein bisschen mit dem Arm.
Aber ich bin lazy.
Handgelenk-Aime lieber.
Deswegen bin ich auch so
faul, was Bewegung angeht.
Ähm,
und versuche schon immer in die richtige
Richtung zu gucken.
Also die richtig guten Spieler siehst du in allen
Games, die predikten, wo die Gegner sind,
aber gucken trotzdem permanent rum, was Sache ist.
Ja, und ich, ich verlasse mich drauf, dass ich
richtig predikte.
Und wenn ich falsch prediktet habe, wo Gegner sind,
bin ich halt am Arsch.
Ich bin da zu faul für.
Excellent.
Das heißt Logitech.
Ich dachte, Logitech, so exquisit.
Gibt es irgendwas, was uns YouTube empfiehlt?
Wir testen den Aldi Schnelltest.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Das Video wollte ich mir schon angucken vorhin.
Also zeigt man den Aldi Schnelltest.
Excellent.
Geht nur ein, geht nur drei Minuten.
Ich will mir den Aldi Schnelltest.
Ich kaufe, dann kaufe ich mir.
Ich kaufe mir morgen den Aldi Schnelltest und dann mache ich dann.
Max Corona, ja oder nein?
Revealed die sind ausverkauft.
Okay, ernsthaft.
Hast du die I Reapts Doku schon gesehen?
Nee, war I Reapts nicht nicht nicht dieses das Mädchen,
was gesagt hat, also die Sniper Clips gemacht hat,
die es gar kein Mädchen war.
Zu MW2 Zeiten oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ich will eigentlich nur sehen, wie er den Test macht.
Wie macht man den Test denn?
Ja, ja, die hatten, die hatten auch garantiert kein Aldi oder sonst was Bonus,
dass sie noch kein WDR Bonus, dass sie noch was bekommen haben.
Garantiert nicht.
Nein, nein.
Ey, gibt es das online zu kaufen?
Ich mache, ich mache Schnelltests in den Preisschamp.
Schnelltest oder oder oder Testschamp.
Okay, wie wie testet man sich damit?
Der Kassierer hat mir gesagt, es gibt nur elf Stück in jeder Filiale und nur noch sechs.
Da doch so viel elf Stück.
Ich habe echt ein bisschen Glück gehabt.
Ich dachte, haben Sie nicht letztens erzählt,
in zwei Tagen startet der Verkauf und sie haben Tausende und jeder kann sich einen kaufen.
Okay, wie so immer ist der Unterschied zwischen was gesagt wird und Realität ein bisschen größer.
Okay, wie wie wie testet man sich?
Nasenbereich sind das 25.
Zeig her, wie testet man sich?
Steckt man sich das in den Hals?
Steckt man sich das in die Nase?
Muss man sich da irgendwie Blut tropfen, tropfen?
Ja, ja, labern.
Ich will einfach.
Ich will wissen, wie man das benutzt.
Ein PR-Test bekommen, schon ausverkauft.
Euro gar nicht so billig.
So funktionieren die Corona-Tests so geil, ne?
Drei Minuten Beitrag, zwei Minuten Schwachsinn.
Und wie funktioniert der Test jetzt?
Aha, hier steht mit einem Stäbchen ins linke Nasenloch, dann ins rechte.
Oh, man soll sich das so weit in die Nase schieben, dass man oben rauskommt.
Ja, ist klar.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist eklig.
Das mache ich nicht.
In so einem Röhrchen.
Du sollst dir das durch die Nase schieben, bis du, bis du quasi hinter der Nase bist.
Igitt.
Oh, das ist ja unangenehm.
Oh.
Reinfüllen.
Vermischen auf so eine Testkassette hier drauf.
Ja, auf, mach, da muss ich das selbst nicht machen.
Ich bin interessiert.
Jawohl, rein damit, rein damit.
Also es ist ein bisschen wichsig.
Danach das Stäbchen 30 Sekunden in die Testflüssigkeit tunken, kurz schütteln und drei Tropfen auf
eine Testkassette.
Das ist wieder hier Exquisite Test, da musst du wieder pfeifert sein, dass du das machen
kannst.
So, jetzt heißt es 15 Minuten warten, dann habe ich das Ergebnis.
Und?
Lass mich raten.
Er hat kein Corona.
15 Minuten sind um.
Ein Strich bei C heißt, ich bin negativ.
Also der Test ist fertig.
Und?
Also der Test ging echt ganz easy durchzuf...
Ich meine, guck mal, die haben 2 Minuten 30 Beitrag gemacht, der eigentlich nur 45 Sekunden
lang sein müsste.
Crap.
Hast du das neue Band?
Ja, habe ich schon gesehen.
Es ist lustig.
Dieses 3 Minuten, woran GitHub Dinger alle ablehnt.
Ja.
So, was habe ich hier übersehen?
Was machen die Chinesen schon wieder?
Ich weiß nicht.
Un BigQuery-Sendung.
Du kannst nur lesen, dass dieser entertainedascal vorbei um professional samurai im Winter 댓gt.
Ich notice that, at the end of the video.
New person today.
Die arriv in China.
Sc lemons dies ist They arrive in China.
喜歡.
Die хорошen kinesischen Sachen.
Die do الع生生 sch customs.
Die, die, die chinesen in China.
ges ist einehalten stunde lang das video.
Das guck ich jetzt nüßt.
Und wenn die Chinesen in China Chemie machen, oje, dann hört's da gar nicht mehr auf.
Hab Ich irgendwas übersehen.
Das kann wir nicht gucken, das geht ne Stunde das Video des zu lang.
Ja!
Und was kommt jetzt in dem Video raus?
Ist das jetzt ein Mädchen oder nicht?
Das ist jetzt das Einzige, was mich interessiert.
War das
MW2-Sniper-Grill
oder nicht?
Tech fails,
they want you to forget. Okay, das können wir gucken.
Gucken wir.
Also wenn der Sirius Max
sagt, dass das ein gutes Video ist, dann können wir
das nochmal mit aufnehmen.
Okay, habe ich was übersehen?
Teleshopping.
Ja, der Karl S.
Ja.
Hast du das gemerkt, ja?
Na gut, der scammt ja aktuell keine Leute mehr.
Hoffe ich mal zumindest.
Mein Vater hat die Leute gescampt früher,
aber ich glaube gerade scammt er sie nicht mehr.
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her,
wo der Leute gescampt hat.
Aber da war ein Profi-Scammer.
Ja, hat er das drauf.
Okay, ich habe nichts vergessen.
Ich habe aber ein Peak-Tutorial. Das war noch Zeiten.
Ne, ne, die habe ich schon
gesehen.
Leko, die Dinger,
die sind immer nicht schlecht.
Habe ich sogar, glaube ich,
sogar noch eins auf davon.
Okay, also,
wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt
die dunkle Wahrheit
hinter .tv-Domains.
Und das gucken wir, während wir auf
twitch.tv sind.
Ich kann euch aber wahrscheinlich schon sagen, was die
dunkle Wahrheit ist, ohne das Video gesehen zu haben.
.tv ist, glaube ich,
eine Domain von irgendeinem
Miniland.
Ich weiß aber nicht,
ob das wirklich die dunkle Wahrheit,
ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, ich weiß, das TV ist keine
neue Domain, wie
.gay
oder so, was es jetzt gibt.
Gibt es wirklich.
Das ist von irgendeinem Land.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Tuvalu, was zum
Tuvalu, Alter.
Island Country
Polynesien
Wo zum Teufel ist das?
Moment.
Das ist so klein, dass es auf Google Maps noch nicht mal zu sehen ist.
Die haben,
die haben bestimmt nicht einen Corona Fall wetten.
Wo ist es?
Da, da ist es.
Also Google Map meint.
Da.
Jutsch, Jutsch.
Wie viel?
Oh, guck mal, das sind Häuser.
Vier Häuser.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Break Island.
Ja, krass, wie viel, wie viel, wie viel Einwohner hat das?
Oh, das ist ehemalige.
Äh, äh, nicht.
Das ist ja die Kona.
Ehemalige.
Ja, was?
Gibt es irgendein schönes britisches Emote?
Tea Time.
Genau, das Tea Time Emote.
Ne.
Three Head Oi sind die Australier.
Na, oder, oder, oder, oder, äh, oder UK Leute mit einem komischen Dialekt.
Geht beides.
Okay, Einwohner.
Elftausend.
Oh, das wären weniger Leute.
Fast 1000 Leute.
Fast 1000 Leute weniger.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt das Witt an.
Funa Falla.
Ja, yes.
Das ist bestimmt nice.
Die haben bestimmt kein Corona.
Exzellent.
Moment, hier.
Internet-Adressen haben verschiedenste Endungen.
Diese Endungen nennt man Top-Level-Domains, kurz TLDs.
Da wäre natürlich die Klassik...
.ru, beste Top-Level-Domain.
...kw.com, .net, .org oder .de.
Es gibt aber auch hippe Domains, wie .tv oder .li
oder für die coolen Supercoder unter euch .io.
Domains kosten Geld.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel...
Ach, ich habe mich in den Jahren vertan.
Okay, da ist es um 1000 gestiegen von 2017 auf 2019.
...TV registrieren will, bezahle ich ca. 25 Euro pro Jahr
plus etwaige extra...
Wie viel?
Sack, Sack.
...TV registrieren will, bezahle ich ca. 25...
Kann durchaus sein, ja.
Gucken wir mal bei meinem Billig-Domain-Registrar,
den ich nicht empfehlen werde, weil es keine DNS-API haben,
aber wo ich ein paar Domains habe.
Also, kek, wait, .tv, 26 Dollar, jo.
Lustigerweise sind .de-Domains und .com-Domains mittlerweile voll billig.
Guck mal, .com ist übelst billig geworden.
Denkt man gar nicht, ne?
...20 Euro pro Jahr plus etwaige Extrakosten.
Und leider steckt hinter dem Geschäft,
mit einigen dieser Endungen, eine dunkle Wahrheit.
Ganz wenige, mächtige Gewinner auf der einen Seite der Erde
und hilflose Verlierer auf der anderen.
Heute geht es um die chaotischen Anfänge des Internets,
skrupellose Geschäftsmänner, ahnungslose Inselstaaten
und digitales Öl.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, ja.
Viele Domains beziehen sich auf bestimmte Länder.
.de.
Für Deutschland zum Beispiel.
Das geht zurück auf den amerikanischen Wissenschaftler John Postel,
der University of California.
Gibt es .cocona?
In den 80ern hat er auf der Basis dieses ISO-Standards
Ich will .cocona haben.
länderspezifische TLDs festgelegt.
Das Internet war damals noch winzig.
Ein kleines Netzwerk, das von einigen wenigen Menschen quasi zusammengetüftelt wurde.
Dementsprechend hat Postel die Administration für verschiedene Länder-Domains
anfangs einfach an sich und ein paar Kollegen verteilt.
.de.
Er selbst hat lange Zeit .us gemanagt.
.uk ging zum Beispiel an einen britischen Professor-Kumpel.
Aber das Internet wurde immer größer und beliebter.
1994 führte Postel deshalb ein paar Regeln für die Vergabe der Länder-Domains ein.
Administratoren sollten zumindest in irgendeiner Art und Weise
etwas mit dem jeweiligen Land zu tun haben.
Was?
Und mindestens eine Person...
Seit wann?
Was sind denn das für Regeln, dass derjenige, der sich um was kümmert, Ahnung haben muss?
Das ist überhaupt...
Das ist einfach so nicht agil und nicht ITIL-konform.
Verwaltung musste tatsächlich dort leben.
Du musst einfach nur regelmäßige Daily Stand-Ups machen und Tribe-Meetings,
dann musst du da keine Ahnung für haben.
So sollte das Internet mithilfe der nationalen Domains zum Wohl aller
in die verschiedenen Länder gebracht und dort ausgebaut werden.
Heute betrachten viele Staaten ihre Domain deshalb als wichtige nationale Ressource.
In fast jedem Land der Welt unterliegen sie einer Form von direkter oder
indirekter staatlicher Kontrolle.
Aber leider ist die Vergabe dieser Länder-Domains in einigen Fällen trotz Postels Grundregeln
ziemlich übel gelaufen.
Viele kleine, weniger entwickelte Länder hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Hat Sealand eigentlich eine Top-Level-Domain?
Mein Lieblings-Insel-Staat?
Weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Guck, das ist übrigens Sealand.
Das ist eine ehemalige Öl-Bohr-Insel.
Wo irgendeiner raufgefahren ist mit dem Schiff und hat gesagt, das ist jetzt mein eigenes Land.
Die haben dann auch Hosting angeboten.
Die Staaten hatten vielleicht Glück mit ihren Länder-Codes,
aber keinen Plan, wie viel eine gute Domain wert sein könnte.
Und so wurden sie teils einfach ausgebeutet.
Tuvalu ist ein winziger Insel-Staat im Pazifischen Ozean mit knapp 12.000 Einwohnern.
Das Land hatte unfassbar viel Glück, denn Tuvalus-TLD ist...
TV.
Die Domain ist spätestens seit Twitch äußerst beliebt, weil naja, TV und Content und naja, ihr checkt schon.
Punkt TV wurde direkt zur Anfangszeit des Internets einfach von einem amerikanischen Programmierer beansprucht,
der nichts mit Tuvalu zu tun hatte.
Tuvalu hat es allerdings recht schnell geschafft, die...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wo ist denn jetzt die dunkle Wahrheit?
...Domain zurückzubekommen.
Danach gab es viele Interessenten.
Aufstrebende amerikanische Internetfirmen mit viel Geld.
Das kleine Land mit kaum IT-Expertise war ziemlich überfordert.
Man unterschrieb einen richtig...
Kokonas am Start!
...Deal mit der amerikanischen Firma VeriSign.
Oh je! Oh je!
Moment, sind das nicht die, die ihren Root-Key verloren haben, oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Nee, das war Komodo, die ihren Root-Key verloren haben.
Nein.
Das Unternehmen sollte die Domains für den Inselstaat für die nächsten zwölf Jahre verkaufen.
Tuvalu bekam dafür zwei Millionen Dollar pro Jahr.
Das waren zu dem Zeitpunkt immerhin rund 15% des gesamten Bruttoinlandsprodukts der Insel.
Und VeriSigns Infrastruktur hat es dem Land überhaupt erst ermöglicht, die TV-Domains im großen Stil zu verkaufen.
Root-Key ist...
Das, wo du als Zertifizierungsstelle quasi die Keys für andere Leute mit, äh, signierst, ausstellst.
Das heißt, wenn jemand deinen Root-Key klaut, kannst du im Namen von einer Zertifizierungsstelle dir selbst Zertifikate ausstellen, den alle trauen.
...kaufen.
Aber gemessen an dem schieren Potenzial und der Beliebtheit von PunktTV waren die zwei Millionen pro Jahr eher mager.
Oder...
Na gut, das war denen halt nicht klar, ne?
...des damaligen Tuvalu-Finanzministers...
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, äh, äh, Tuvalu hätte sich ja auch mal ein bisschen schlau machen können.
Wenn irgendwie ein Random-Dude zu mir kommt und sagt, ey Max, ich will das von dir unbedingt kaufen, ich geb dir zwei Millionen für, das erste, was ich mach, ist erstmal zu gucken, okay, äh, was will der eigentlich von mir und, und was ist das, ja?
Also ich mein, ich bin ja nicht gezwungen, das Instant-Morgen an den Typ zu verkaufen, also die hätten ja auch mal ein bisschen...
...gucken können.
...endlich einen besseren...
Und wenn das in den 90ern waren, ist wahrscheinlich zwei Millionen für Domains gar nicht mal so scheiße.
...handeln und bekommt jetzt immerhin fünf Millionen Dollar pro Jahr.
Der Inselstaat wurde in gewisser Weise von einem großen Konzern ausgenutzt und hat für mindestens ein Jahrzehnt viel zu wenig Geld bekommen.
Aber immerhin gehört dem Land die eigene...
Sie haben, ey, sie haben den Kram unterschrieben, ja?
Naja.
...Domain...
Ich mein, ich kann mich da auch nicht beschweren.
Wenn ich irgendwie Crap unterschreibe und danach muss ich mich dran halten.
...mitreden.
Niue hat es da viel härter erwischt.
NU hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Niue ist ein winzig kleiner Inselstaat im südpazifischen Ozean mit circa 1600 Einwohnern.
Niue?
1997 hat sich der Amerikaner Bill Samage die Kontrolle über Punkt NU gesichert.
Das ist die Top-Level-Domain des Landes.
Samage?
Ne.
Auf Niederländisch, Dänisch und Schwedisch bedeutet Nü, nämlich jetzt.
Samage verdient sich in den folgenden Jahren dumm und dämlich mit Punkt NU,
2013 lizenziert er die Rechte schließlich an die Schwedische Internetstiftung.
Internet, was für ein Ding?
Internetstiftelsen.
Schwedische Internetstiftung.
Dabei hat Niue schon im Jahr 2000 gesetzlich festgelegt, dass ihre Domain eine nationale Ressource ist, über die der niueanische Staat entscheidet.
Trotzdem hat ihnen niemand ihre Domain zurückgegeben.
Weder Bill Sammich noch die Schwedische Stiftung.
Aber hey, der Philanthrop Sammich versorgt Niue gemäß des Deals doch immerhin gratis mit Internet.
Das klingt ja voll großzügig und so.
Das hier ist die Webseite der entsprechenden Stiftung von Sammich.
Einfach mal einen Mast gebaut und das ist Internetversorgung. Excellent.
Ist ja fast wie bei uns.
Die IUSN Stiftung hilft Schwellen.
Schwellenländern dabei in die internationale Internet-Community einzutreten.
Naja, das Gratis-Internet für die Bevölkerung der Insel war schon immer das absolute Minimum und hat Niue auch nur im Ansatz alle 1500 Bürger erreicht.
Vielleicht symbolisch.
Das hier ist das Internetgebäude der IUSN Stiftung auf Niue.
Okay, das ist echt.
Aber immerhin eine Klimaanlage, ja?
Ey, da ist ja mein Serverraum mehr Hightech.
Ich mein, was meint ihr, wie das Ding von innen aussieht?
Ich glaube, da bin ich fast schon besser dran.
Ist das vielleicht ein Telekom-Schalterhäuschen?
Jedenfalls hat Niue die Schwedische Internetstiftung 2018 verklagt.
Schweden ist ein Land, das internationale Standards und Werte sehr hoch hält.
Ich bin für das bekannt.
Es ist auch ein extrem entwickeltes Internet.
Also ist es ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass Niue in Schweden zum Zivilgericht gehen muss.
Das ist Per Brumak, ein schwedischer Domain-Experte, der Niue in diesem Fall vertritt.
Er schätzt, dass dem Inselstaat durch den Verlust der .nu-Domain ungefähr 125 Millionen Euro Umsatz entgangen sind.
Dann wäre da noch .io.
I.O. steht in IT-Kreisen für...
Ja, okay, das kenne ich.
Aber jetzt mal.
Was zu .tv.
Also, es ist in gewisser Weise schon verwerflich, wenn du quasi ausnutzt, dass die anderen keine Ahnung haben.
Aber da muss man sich jetzt fragen, ist das jetzt echt der Fail von den Amis oder so in dem Fall?
Also ich würde eher sagen, das ist einmal natürlich die Amis, die das gnadenlos ausgenutzt haben in dem Fall.
Aber auch letztendlich ein bisschen der Fail von der Regierung von...
Tuadingsbums, ich habe vergessen, wie sie heißen.
Weil die hätten sich ja auch mal schlau machen können.
Also es wäre ihr Job gewesen, sich mal schlau zu machen.
Tuvalu, ja.
Und in den 90ern weiß ich gar nicht mal, ob 2 Millionen für die Domains so wenig waren.
Und war so, letztendlich hat es die Regierung von Tuvalu verkackt, sich nicht schlau gemacht, den Kram unterschrieben.
Das ist so, wie wenn ich damals für 10.000 Bitcoin...
... eine Pizza bestellt habe und mich heute darüber aufrege.
Ich muss halt einfach gucken.
Ich habe damals gesagt, ich hätte gerne Pizza für 10.000 Bitcoins.
Und jemand hat mir eine Pizza geliefert für 10.000 Bitcoins.
Ja, hier übergeben und gut ist.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich das so dunkel und verwerflich finden kann.
Ja.
Man hätte durchaus in den Vertrag.
Genau.
Man hätte den Vertrag zum Beispiel aufnehmen können, dass das je nach Entwicklung irgendwie was anderes passiert.
Oder dass es nur zeitlich so und so beschränkt ist.
Oder dass es geknüpft ist an irgendwas, ja.
Also man hätte sich damals auch da irgendwas holen können.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie irgendein Ureinwohnervolk im Busch ist.
Das waren ja schon, sonst hätten die auch gar keinen Top-Level-Domain.
Das waren halt welche, die saumäßig abgeschieden gelebt haben.
Aber das war schon zivilisierte Leute in dem Sinne.
Also die wussten, die haben nicht mehr gedacht, die Erde ist eine Scheibe.
Wobei, das darf man ja so nicht sagen, weil es gibt ja immer noch welche.
Ja, also ich finde es jetzt nicht so verwerflich.
Online-Games und Web-Services.
Die Domain gehört eigentlich zum British Indian Ocean Territory.
Das sind im Prinzip die Chagos.
Und oh boy, ist das eine düstere Geschichte.
In Kurzfassung.
Ursprünglich gehören die Chagos-Inseln zu Mauritius.
Das ist ein Inselstaat, der wiederum von 1810 bis 1968 eine britische Kolonie war.
Drei Jahre vor der Unabhängigkeit hat Großbritannien die Inselgruppe einfach von Mauritius abgetrennt und gesagt,
das ist ab jetzt das British Indian Ocean Territory.
Dann hat man ein geheimes Abkommen mit den USA geschlossen,
dort eine gewaltige Militärbasis zu errichten.
Blöd nur, dass auf den Inseln rund 2000 einheimische Chagossianer gelebt haben.
Chagossianer?
Ach, was es alles gibt.
Zitat.
Tarzane und Freitage hat man einfach kurzerhand deportiert.
Oh, das wäre, allein schon die Erwähnung wäre heute Riesenskandal.
Seitdem sind die Inseln ein herrlicher strategischer Stützpunkt.
Und es wurde sogar ein schönes kleines Foltergefängnis der CIA dorthin gepackt.
Bis heute wurden die Chagoss-Inseln nicht an Mauritius zurückgegeben.
Und das, obwohl die UN den britischen Anspruch auf die Inseln in mehreren Instanzen niedergeschmettert hat.
Ach so, natürlich haben die vertriebenen Chagossianer...
Wen juckt das bei den Amis?
...an .io verdient.
Die Domain wird von einem britischen Unternehmen verweilt.
Und die UK-Leute juckt das auch nicht.
Ein Wired-Artikel zu dieser Thematik nennt diese Fälle digitalen Kolonialismus.
Ist das übertrieben?
Ja, da hat er nicht ohne Recht.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, die haben eingewilligt.
Es ist nicht so, dass man, wie damals hingefahren ist, man hat eine Fahne aufgestellt und hat gesagt, wir haben jetzt hier das Sagen und im Zweifelsfall erschießen wir euch.
Ich meine, die haben immerhin freiwillig...
zugestimmt.
Das ist ja schon ein kleiner Unterschied.
Wenn man Öl findet, in einem Land, in dem man nicht für Öl grillt, und man grillt immer noch für Öl.
Also ich meine jetzt die ersten, nicht die letzten.
Die Internetstiftung schreibt uns gegenüber in einer Stellungnahme, ihre Kontrolle der .nu-Domain geschehe innerhalb der aufgestellten Regeln.
Schließlich sei Bill Sammich in den 90ern rechtmäßig zum Manager von .nu ernannt worden und er habe nur die Administration übergeben.
So sind Domains wie .tv, .nu...
oder .io zu einem gewissen Grad ein Spiegel der Machtstrukturen unserer Zeit.
Ja.
Sie sind Teil eines Systems, in dem jeder erstmal die gleichen Rechte hat, aber letztlich gelten diese Rechte dann doch etwas mehr für Schweden als für irgendeine Insel im südpazifischen Ozean.
Für uns entblößen die Geschichten dieser Kürzel eine bittere Doppelmoral.
Im harschen Kontrast zu unseren gesellschaftlichen Werten und dem egalitären Grundgesetz.
Und Gedanken des Internets.
Winzig kleine Nationen, ihre Ressourcen, ihr digitales Öl wegzunehmen.
Naja, digitales Öl ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen hochgegriffen.
Und irgendwo neokolonial.
Cheers.
Er hat schon nicht, er hat irgendwo nicht Unrecht.
Hoffentlich hat euch dieses Video...
Aber gerade bei den ersten weiß ich nicht, ob ich das jetzt so dunkel oder so extrem verwerflich finden soll, wie er es dargestellt hat.
Seherlich haben sie die schon...
Sie haben sie schon irgendwo gescampt.
Aber zumindest gescampt mit Zustimmung.
Nichtsdestotrotz gescampt.
Wo empfiehlst du eine Domain zu holen, kann ich dir nichts empfehlen.
Also ich hab bei denen hier meine Domains geholt, aber die sacken, weil die keine DNS-API haben.
Und ich bin auch nur noch da, weil ich da ein paar Domains hab.
Und weil die billig as fuck waren.
Ne, was ist, guck ich schnell an.
Ey, das hab ich damals auch gesagt.
Hier, ähm...
Also solange das...
Ne?
Ich bin nicht gegen irgendwelche Verträge, die rechtlich fragwürdig sind, ja.
Aber ich hab damals auch schon gesagt, wo es bei diesen ganzen...
Kann sich noch einer an diese Sache Freiheit für Unge erinnern?
Ich hab damals auch gesagt, Alter, wenn man halt die Sache unterschreibt, nur weil man es nicht besser weiß, ist man selber dran schuld.
Und das sag ich als jemand, der genau den gleichen Scheiß hatte.
Der bei Weißem natürlich nicht so groß ist und nicht so viele Sachen auf sich gezogen hat, ja.
Ich hatte genau den gleichen Scheiß wie er.
Mit nem YouTube-Netzwerk.
Nur, dass ich damals nicht einfach quitten konnte, weil die in England gesessen haben.
Ich find das auch, ich find das genauso scheiße, ja.
Aber eins, ich hab...
Das Wichtige ist ja, was man daraus lernt.
Und was ich daraus gelernt hab, ist...
Man muss sich den Scheiß...
Also man muss es wörtlich nehmen, was in so nem Vertrag drinnen steht.
Nicht nach dem Motto...
Also was Scammer gerne machen, ist...
Sie erzählen dir was.
Oder was heißt Scammer?
Sag mal...
Ja, doch, Scammer.
Sag mal, können wir Scammer nennen.
Also was Scammer gerne machen, ist, sie erzählen dir irgendwas, was du geil findest.
Dann schicken sie dir einen Vertrag, in dem steht das ein bisschen anders formuliert drin, ne.
Aber sagen sie...
Sie sagen dann...
Ja, nee.
Das ist schon so, wie ich's dir gesagt hab, aber...
Wir brauchen das nur, dass es rechtlich konform ist.
Oder sowas, ja.
Und dann unterschreibst du den Scheiß.
Du musst das...
Und das ist wirklich die Sache, die ich mittlerweile gelernt hab.
Also spätestens seit der YouTube-Netzwerk steht.
Du musst das wirklich so nehmen, wie's da drin steht.
Und wenn da Sachen drinne stehen, die man...
Eventuell zu deinen Ungunsten auslegen kann, dann kannst du von ausgehen, die werden zu deinen Ungunsten ausgelegt.
Und da hast du halt gelitten, ja.
Und wenn du einen Vertrag unterschreibst, wo dann da steht, der Gerichtsstand ist London, dann bist du schon mal gefickt.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Es sei denn, es ist irgendwas, wo du von deiner Seite aus easy beenden kannst, ja.
Also zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ja.
Wenn du jetzt mit irgendeinem Scammer einen Vertrag machst.
Und sag mal...
Sagen wir mal so.
Sagen wir mal, G2A hätte mit mir irgendwie einen merkwürdigen Vertrag gemacht.
Und ich könnte einseitig sagen, ey, ich halt mich da nicht dran.
Und ich könnte das einfach machen, dann müsste mich ja G2A verklagen.
Ja, das werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Aber bei YouTube-Netzwerken ist das anders.
Dein Channel ist ja gelinkt zu diesem Netzwerk.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht einfach einseitig sagen, ich scheiß auf den Vertrag und bin weg.
Die müssen dich freigeben.
Zumindest war das früher so.
Und das heißt...
Wir müssen halt genau gucken.
Wenn du irgendeinen Mist unterschreibst mit Gerichtsstand ist London, du bist auf drei Jahre oder unendlich lang verpflichtet, bla bla bla.
Dann hast du halt dummes Zeug unterschrieben.
Hatte ich genau das gleiche Problem, hatte ich auch.
Und wir sind dann nur rausgekommen, weil der Channel-Betreiber damals das Netzwerk verkauft hat und uns gegen YouTube Bedingungen verstoßen hat.
Kann ich an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal erzählen.
Wir waren ja bei, wie hieß denn das, irgendeinem englischen Netzwerk, ganz am Anfang.
Und ich hab halt das dumme Gelaber geklaubt damals noch.
Und der Typ hat irgendwann sein Netzwerk...
Der wollte uns dann nicht mehr rauslassen, partout, ne.
Na gut, wir haben den Kram unterschrieben.
YouTube hat auch gesagt, ja, verklagt ihn halt.
Wir machen da nix.
Und wir sind dann nur rausgekommen, weil er hat das Netzwerk verkauft und hat gegen YouTube Bedingungen verstoßen,
indem er...
Und jetzt kommt's, seine eigenen Videos gestrikt hat.
Der Typ wollte uns damals unter Druck setzen.
Wir sollen den Vertrag umstellen lassen von seinem Netzwerk auf das neue Netzwerk.
Und um uns unter Druck zu setzen, hat er quasi Videos von uns gestrikt...
Also er hat quasi Videos von seinem eigenen Netzwerk gestrikt.
Ohne Sinn und Verstand, ja.
Und das hat YouTube dann nicht so gefallen.
Sonst wären wir da wahrscheinlich nicht rausgekommen.
Kommt zu Battlefield.
Battlefield 6 wieder ein Wunschzettel-Video.
Ich glaube, ich hab sogar schon mal...
Ich hab doch sogar schon ein Video gemacht zu Battlefield 6 in letzter Zeit, oder nicht?
Ich hab ab und zu mal was gesagt zu Battlefield 6.
Hier, da hab ich doch mal was zu gesagt, wo ich weiß, was ich denke.
Aber aktuell kann man dazu noch gar nix sagen, weil es gibt ja noch null Infos.
Auf was für eine Verdauer ist ein Vertrag ausgelegt?
Das kommt auf den Vertrag an.
Unser Vertrag damals war klar...
Glaube ich für immer.
Oder auf jeden Fall für ne ewig lange Zeit.
Also der Vertrag wär in Deutschland absolut nicht gültig gewesen, aber in der UK hätte ich...
Ich hätte halt nach London gehen müssen, die Typen verklagen.
Battlefield 6 wird Skill-Based Matchmaking haben.
Oh ja, die doofe Vermutung hab ich auch.
Die doofe Vermutung hab ich auch.
Ja, Florian, wenn's ein guter Job ist, dann ist ja nicht schlimm.
Wenn's was taugt.
Advanced Dashboards.
Zeig her.
Ha!
Der hat jetzt genau das gleiche gemacht wie ich.
Das ist auch ein Amazon Fire.
Ich hab auch so ein Dashboard an der Wand hängen mit Amazon Fire.
Aber nicht mit Smart Things.
Smart Things sucked.
Home Assistant.
Beste.
Ja, so sieht das...
Ja, so, so ziemlich genau sieht das bei mir an der Wand auch aus.
Also die Spotify-Gedöns und so ist da nicht drauf.
Aber so ungefähr sieht das bei mir an der Wand auch aus.
Beste.
Ach ja, und bei den Amis, bei den Amis hast du den großen Vorteil, die Kokona-Bauweise erlaubt ja, dass man mit einer Säge einfach Löcher in die Wand sägt.
Matze, vielleicht gibt's keinen Server-Browser mehr.
Und das geht ja bei uns nicht.
Skill-Based Matchmaking sorgt auch dafür, dass die Noobs keinen Spaß haben, weil es durch die Bank weg bei allen dafür sorgt, dass sie quasi immer tryharden müssen, um ihre 50-50 zu haben.
Also im Prinzip macht's eigentlich für alle weniger Spaß.
Bin ich der Überzeugung.
Das Einzige, was es bringt, ist, dass die Hersteller irgendwelche Microtransactions pushen können.
Ja, die Ami-Häuser sind ja aus...
Die Kokona-Häuser sind ja aus Holz.
Eigentlich, ich mach mich ja immer so lustig drüber, über die Ami...
Ich find die Idee von Holzhäusern gar nicht mal so doof.
Ich mein, wenn man das in irgendeinem Wirbelsturm-Gebiet macht...
...ist schon Fail und dann muss man sich nicht wundern, warum die Häuser wegfliegen.
Aber an sich find ich die Idee gar nicht schlecht.
Das lässt sich schneller, einfacher und billiger bauen und umbauen als Steilhäuser.
Übrigens, Venice Unleashed ist...
Und es ist günstiger.
Venice Unleashed ist dead.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, warum.
Die hat eine ganze Zeit lang Memory League.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das weg ist.
Aber es ist dead.
Ich versteh's nicht so genau, weil eigentlich hat sich's richtig gut gespielt.
Aber...
RIP.
Nein.
Ja, ja, Battlefield 3 übers Battlelog ist noch was los, ja.
Also, ich muss ja auch sagen, Venice, finde ich, spielt sich auch besser als, ähm...
...Vanilla.
So.
Die besten Gaming-Monitor.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Mini Raspberry Pi Silent Homelab.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Ich, ich, ich call es jetzt schon mal.
Es ist...
Es ist komplett sinnlos.
Ähm...
Und eigentlich eher so ein Bastelprojekt, als dass es was bringt.
Ja, nach dem Venice Release kam nicht mehr viel.
Das ist echt problematisch.
Jeff!
Aber nicht Jeff from the Overwatch Team.
Alter, kann der das noch...
Kann der noch leiser reden, vielleicht?
Okay, wir spulen jetzt ein bisschen vor.
Ich will nämlich sehen, was, was er, was er baut.
Parts.
Auf geht's.
Nettes, ein hübsches Rack hat er da.
Ein hübsches, äh, hübsches Mini-Rack hat er da.
Da unten ist, ist das eine USV oder, oder zumindest, zumindest irgendwie so ein Stromverteilungsding?
Sag mal, ist der Raum schräg?
Oder ist die Kamera schräg?
Ich vermute mal, die Kamera ist schräg.
Aber es sieht aus, als wäre der Raum schräg.
Wobei, Kokona, Kokona-Bauweise, man weiß nie.
Vielleicht ist der Raum ja schräg.
Holzhaus.
Exzellent.
So, die Geräte hier, wir haben einen Router, einen Controller.
Was hältst du von...
Oh, da kann ich mal, da kann...
Okay, Leute.
Kurze, kurze Laber-Unterbrechung.
Was hältst du von Python als erste Programmiersprache?
Ich muss unbedingt ein Video zu diesem Thema machen, weil das gibt es jeden Stream, diese Frage, und nicht nur einmal.
Also, ich bin der Meinung, die beste Einstiegsprogrammiersprache, wenn man auch nicht genau weiß, was man machen will, aktuell, nach aktuellem Stand, ist JavaScript im Browser.
JavaScript, HTML, CSS.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil du dann siehst, was passiert.
Und man an Web-Entwicklungen...
Und man an Web-Entwicklungen eh nicht vorbeikommt heutzutage.
Wenn du allerdings schon weißt, und man kann auch wunderbar mit JavaScript die Basics lernen, ja.
So, wenn du allerdings schon weißt, was du machen willst, dann gibt es ein paar andere Sachen, die sich anbieten würden, ja.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel weißt, du möchtest irgendwelche AI-Geschichten machen oder vielleicht Server-Automatisierung, Scripting, sonst was.
Oder Dinge, die sich halt in Python anbieten, dann spricht da absolut nichts dagegen.
Deswegen ist das als erste Sprache zu nehmen.
Das ist eine super Programmiersprache zum Anfang, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, da kann man sich gleich schon mal dran gewöhnen, dass alle Programmiersprachen irgendwelche wirren Dinger haben.
Was hältst du von Assembler als erste Programmiersprache? Welchen Assembler denn?
Ja, gut, Java.
Also, Python ist eine gute Programmiersprache zum Einstieg.
Ruby auch.
Allerdings ist Ruby an sich nicht mehr so angesagt.
Ich persönlich mag ja C-Sharp und .NET auch als Einstieg.
Ja.
Das ist viel leichter.
Wenn du eine Programmiersprache kannst, lernst du die anderen in zwei, drei Tagen so weit, dass du sie gut benutzen kannst.
Du lernst dann weniger die Programmiersprache, du lernst dann mehr die Standard-Library von den Sprachen, wenn du eine Sprache kannst.
Und C++ würde ich auf keinen Fall zum Einstieg machen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bin auch großer Fan von .NET, C-Sharp zum Programmieren, Einsteigen.
Weil der Vorteil von C-Sharp ist, ich finde es ist...
Es ist die aktuell universalste Programmiersprache, die es gibt, was du machen kannst.
Du kannst von Server-Anwendungen bis zu Web-Anwendungen bis zu GUI-Anwendungen, Cross-Plattform-Sachen, du kannst alles machen.
Und das Ganze in einer schönen Sprache.
Du magst das eventuell auch in C++ machen können, aber C++ ist eine Kacksprache.
Und C-Sharp ist eine hübsche Sprache.
Ja, du kannst fast alles, so sieht es aus.
Du kannst fast alles.
In C-Sharp machen.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, das geht schlecht.
Beste Programmiersprache zum Ausstieg, Kobol, würde ich sagen.
Oder meinst du zum Aufstieg?
Übrigens, Leute, der Herr Endpunkt hat sich bei mir gemeldet aus dem letzten Video.
Habe ich euch das eigentlich erzählt?
Hat sich bei mir im Discord gemeldet.
Richtig pock, ja.
So, also es gibt ein paar Sachen.
Und er sagt, er macht immer noch...
Er macht immer noch IT.
Ah, da hat er erzählt.
So, du kannst fast alles gut.
Das stimmt.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die mir einfallen, die nicht gut in C-Sharp gehen.
Wie gesagt, einen Bootmanager oder so kannst du nicht unbedingt machen.
Ein Betriebssystem rein in C-Sharp ist wahrscheinlich auch nichts.
Aber ansonsten, meinetwegen von Smartphone-Anwendungen geht es am vielleicht nicht so schön.
Zu Cross-Plattformen, GUI-Sachen, zu Web-Anwendungen, zu Server-Sachen.
Du kannst alles drin machen.
Also ich finde, deswegen ist C-Sharp ein schöner Einstieg.
Weil C-Sharp kannst du alles mitmachen.
Du kannst theoretisch mit C-Sharp anfangen und nie was anderes machen.
Und trotzdem mehr oder weniger alles programmieren.
Ja, habe ich schon gehört.
Habe ich auch nichts mitgemacht mit NIM.
Das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Die Leute, die sowas denken, müssen nicht mal ganz dicht sein.
Also wie man C++ lieben kann, erschließt sich mir schon mal gar nicht.
Aber umgekehrt.
Also, ich glaube, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Also, C-Sharp ist eine wunderbar, zum größten Teil, konsistente und nachvollziehbare Sprache.
Also das komplette Gegenteil von C++.
Das ist auch ein Vorteil, dass du ältere C-Sharp und .NET-Versionen in Windows mit eingebaut hast.
Aber du kannst auch wunderbar Standalone-Anwendungen mittlerweile machen, ohne dass du das Framework installieren musst.
Ja, ja, ja, das war der Originale.
Swift. Zu Swift kann ich nichts sagen.
Habe ich da nichts mitgemacht.
Nein, ich habe nichts mitgemacht.
Ich finde es nicht sinnvoll, Assembler in der Schule zu machen.
Schon gar nicht zum Einstieg.
Am Anfang würde ich TypeScript weglassen, wenn ich ganz neu einsteige.
Dann würde ich einfach nur JavaScript machen.
Nee, Microsoft schafft es ja nicht mal, ein ordentliches Windows-GUI-Framework rauszubringen.
WinUI 3.0 hat sich gut gelesen, aber sie haben es nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ich weiß nicht, was Microsoft macht.
Die müssen sich nicht wundern.
Die müssen sich nicht wundern, wenn alle Welt...
Welt-Elektron-Anwendungen macht.
Du brauchst...
Also wenn es ein .NET Core-Projekt ist, ist es easy.
Um ein .NET Core-Projekt zu bilden, brauchst du noch nicht mal eine IDE.
Dann sagst du einfach .NET Run und gut ist.
UWP suckt einfach nur Hardcore.
Die mögen ja UWP selber nicht mehr.
Deswegen haben sie jetzt WinUI gemacht, was quasi UWP weiterentwickelt und für mehr Anwendungstypen benutzt werden kann.
Aber sie haben es immer noch nicht geschafft, Unpackaged-Apps zu machen.
Das Wichtigste, was man bräuchte unter Windows, ja.
Es holt sich doch keiner ein Codesigning-Zertifikat einfach mal random, wenn er sagt, ich könnte auch eine Windows-Anwendung machen.
Dann läuft das darauf raus, dass die Leute anfangen, Elektron zu verwenden als Cross-Plattform-Framework.
Was eigentlich für alle Beteiligten suckt.
Naja gut, gucken wir mal weiter.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier Schönes zu bieten?
Excellent.
Pi-Cluster.
Pongas.
Teams ist mit Elektron gemacht.
Ja, das ergibt aber auch Sinn, weil Teams in Browsern laufen soll.
Was hat er da?
Mini-Kabel?
Sind das irgendeine Netgear oder so?
Okay, Leute, ernsthaft?
Das sind die kürzesten Netzwerkkabel, die ich je gesehen habe.
USB-SATA.
Ja, die sind aus Ägypten.
Deswegen haben die so eine Pyramide.
Das ist eine Pyramidenform.
Ist das, hat er das, ne, das ist, Moment, das hat er nicht 3D gedruckt, oder?
Das sieht so metallern aus.
Echt?
3D.
Print 3D, okay, Leute, Leute, ich muss mal kurz suchen.
Man kann sich, man kann sich Rackmounts 3D drucken, gescheit.
Die halten dann auch.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, da muss ich mal kurz, kurz Thingiverse anschmeißen und mal schnell schauen.
Wobei, warum mache ich eigentlich meine VM dafür an?
Das ist doch komplett hängen geblieben.
Null.
Dann lasse ich das Video hier im Fullscreen und gut, das, das muss ich mir mal kurz angucken.
Das muss ich mal kurz, kurz, kurz Musik anmachen wieder.
Wait, wait a minute.
Keck, wait, keck, wait.
Das Thingiverse.
Nein, das Netzwerk ist nicht disconnected, sonst könnte es jetzt, äh, Rack, Rack, Mount, Mount, ha!
Print 3D, Print 3D Steve.
Das da?
Okay.
Guck mal hier!
Haha!
Hey, das ist cool!
Das druckt man aber doch bestimmt in einzelnen Teilen.
Gibt es, äh, gibt es auch sowas, wo einfach, wo man einfach nur was draufstellt?
Hey, das ist cool!
Wow!
Okay, jetzt wird's übertrieben.
Ja, okay, ey, ist ja gut, ist ja, ist ja gut, jetzt, jetzt übertreibt man nicht.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf, dreizehn Raspberry Pis, okay, das wird vielleicht, äh, zwölf.
Hab ich mich verzählt?
Hab ich mich verzählt, Leute?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf, dreizehn!
Da, da steht zwölf!
Hat der sich verzählt oder ich mich jetzt verzählt?
Keck, wait!
Bracket.
Eins ist mit einem Interface.
Ach so, das kann man nicht alles reinstöpseln.
Guck mal, sogar Metall machen die hier hinten dran.
Ah, ne, das ist auch eine 3D-gedruckte Unterlage.
Moment, wie soll ich denn das rack-mountain?
Ach, nur auf einer Seite festschrauben, oder was?
Das check ich nicht, wie das funktioniert, das ist mir zu hoch.
Ja, nur auf einer Seite festschrauben, hier festschrauben.
Hey, das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Da kann man den Raspberry Pi an einer Seite festhängen.
Interessant, was nicht, was, ah, hier, Moment.
Okay.
Ah, das ist, dass ich was rack-mounted, das unter meinem Schreibtisch mountet.
Und dann kann ich auch 3D-drucken.
Eigentlich auch eine coole Sache.
Nicht, dass ich es brauchen würde, aber, boah.
Okay, guck mal weiter.
Man kann exzellent 3D-drucken.
Finde ich echt nice.
Wobei das eigentlich ganz cool wäre, da könnte ich mein...
Ey, das ist nice.
Ich habe mir doch diesen Switch hier gekauft.
Der ist doch, der ist doch für einen, für einen Schreibtisch habe ich mir den gekauft.
Eigentlich war mein Plan, ich stelle den auf den Schreibtisch drauf.
Aber.
Aber, hier werden, hier werden ja so rack-mount mitgeliefert.
Auf einer Seite.
Es reicht auf einer Seite, weil das Ding ist nicht so schwer.
Oder vielleicht doch auf beiden Seiten.
Mal gucken.
Außerdem habe ich noch so Brackets übrig.
Den könnte ich mir eigentlich hinten unter den Schreibtisch hängen.
Anstatt es auf den Schreibtisch zu stellen.
Auf der anderen Seite komme ich dann schlecht dran.
Da muss ich jedes Mal unter den Tisch krabbeln.
Hm.
Mal, mal überlegen.
Gucken wir, gucken wir erstmal weiter.
Was baut er denn sonst noch?
3D-Druck.
3D-Steve.
Und so I had them made these special Raspberry Pi.
He had the special Raspberry Pi mounts.
Das ist auf jeden...
Aber das fände ich, das fände ich auf jeden Fall schon mal nice, dass man sich das ausdrucken kann.
Wow.
Switch.
Äh, the...
So ist wie ne Festplatte.
Äh, Cloud Controller.
Der Cloud Controller?
Hat der einen UniFi-Controller, oder?
And then the router.
Router.
So these are pretty interesting.
Because they have...
...screws here, so you can actually take these off and combine them into different forms.
Der Router.
Like we could...
Hardcore Resi, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Huge IQ-Subscription.
I'm just gonna keep the Raspberry Pi one for myself, actually.
Was war das? War das ein TP-Link?
Das hab ich jetzt nicht gesehen.
Ja, ist ein TP-Link.
Hey, TP-Link ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, ganz brauchbar.
Ich hatte auch jahrelang so den billigsten vom billigsten.
Also wirklich das aller, aller, aller...
...billigste TP-Link-Switch mit im Netzwerk hat nie Probleme gemacht.
Also unmanaged und 5 Euro oder sowas der gekostet hat.
Like we could combine these two together.
But what I'm gonna do is keep the Raspberry Pi one for myself, actually.
And I actually have a line, so this one can only fit four, but I'm talking to somebody who can fit five in it.
Äh, Sirius Max, ne, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ist ja witzig.
We'll see how that works out.
Also wenn er nicht mal Rockstar-Jason parsen kann...
So...
Warum, äh, warum parsen die überhaupt Jason selbst?
Kann man nicht einfach eine Jason-Library verwenden, die das für einen macht?
Man muss, man muss doch nicht jeden Mist nachprogrammieren.
Test fit our devices, I actually haven't tried to fit them in, so...
Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Da erzählt er uns Mist, der hat garantiert schon probiert, ob es reinpasst.
Äh, man wäre, man wäre einfach total bescheuert, wenn man ein Video aufnimmt, um zu zeigen, wie man es zusammenbaut und vorher nicht probiert hat, ob es reinpasst.
Dann müsste man nämlich einfach, wenn es nicht reinpasst, dann muss man es nicht probieren.
Dann müsste man eigentlich das Video instant ausmachen, also das, äh, garantiert hat er es vorher ausprobiert.
Und jetzt, Leute, Leute, huge, huge reveal, huge, massive reveal, ich habe euch auch schon Mist erzählt in Videos.
Ich habe auch schon in Videos gesagt, ich probiere das jetzt zum ersten Mal aus und in Wirklichkeit habe ich es vorher schon mal ausprobiert.
Huge leak, ich weiß.
Hätte, hätte man nie gedacht vorher, aber scripted, ja.
Des-Abo, De-Abo, Lügenpresse, alles raus, ja.
Ja, ja, so sieht es aus, so sieht es aus, ja, revealed.
Link bestimmt auch an 5G.
Anzeige ist raus.
Des-Abo macht man.
Guck mal, wie gut das passt.
Naja, du hältst ihn ja auch fest.
Der hält ihn ja auch fest.
Doesn't even fall out when I shake it.
There's the cloud controller.
Perfect.
Okay, ich mach ein bisschen weiter.
Der Rauder.
Ah, der ist aber ganz schön, der geht aber kaum rein.
Wow, wow, wow.
Wow.
So, okay, wir spulen mal ein bisschen vor.
Ich meine, es sieht, ey, ohne Mist, für selbst gedruckt sieht das ziemlich gut aus.
Wow.
Der Cloud-Controller, das frage ich mich auch.
Was da wie kontrolliert.
Ist das dieser TP-Link-Unify-Abklatsch?
Den die jetzt gemacht haben?
Was er da als Cloud-Controller...
TP-Link hat doch jetzt so einen Unify-Abklatsch.
Boah, jetzt hat er aber das Gain an seinem Mikrofon hochgedreht.
Stimmt.
Perfekt.
Fit, ob es wohl passt.
Okay, weiter, weiter, weiter.
PoE.
Oh.
Ah, der macht die Raspberry-Stick-PoE.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, wie er das macht.
Also, was ich kenne, ist, es gibt so Adapter, die splitten deinen PoE zu Netzwerk und einem USB-C-Stecker für den Raspberry Pi.
Die kenne ich.
Aber es wäre richtig cool, wenn man mal einen Raspberry Pi bekommen würde, der ein eingebautes PoE hat.
Ja, okay, diese Karten gibt es auch noch.
Okay, wir haben den ersten da drauf.
Und wie kriegt man da jetzt PoE dran?
Ja, okay.
Wie macht man da jetzt PoE dran?
Weil ich meine, rein ins Netzwerk reinstecken bringt ja auch nichts, wenn der Head da oben drauf ist, oder?
Wie kriegt man da jetzt den Strom dran?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Nest Mal obeilen.
Racking
Berücksichtigen wir diese zwei so dass wir ihn dort Unlessw الب
Sie sind vier Extrapins?
Ja, genau.
Und wie kommt dies aus Never Cable an die vier Extrapins.
Ich gebe Spinte beiseite, weil diese beiden sind PoE-begreifbar.
Über GPIO.
Wie kommt es aus dem Netzwerkkabel an die GPIO-Pins?
Du hast einen A45-Stecker.
Wie kommt das von den Adern, auf denen das Netzwerkkabel drauf ist, auf die GPIO-Pins?
Irgendwie muss das da hinkommen.
Über den Netzwerkanschluss wird es nicht funktionieren.
Wireless-Strom.
5G. Ah, ja okay, das passt.
5G ist im Zweifelsfall, kriegt das alles.
Alles brauchbar.
Okay, also lassen wir uns ein bisschen schneller anpassen.
Also alles passt, wir brauchen nur noch ein wenig Kabelmanagement.
Aber die roten Kabel sind für PoE.
Okay, viel passiert da glaube ich nicht mehr.
Was ich mich jetzt nur frage ist,
but why?
Ich meine, könnte er sich nicht einfach einen Low-Power-Intel da reinstellen,
der schneller ist als zwei Pis und wahrscheinlich auch noch einfacher zu managen?
Ich meine, es geht, das ist auf jeden Fall nice.
Ich habe ja auch einen Raspberry Pi drin, aber der hängt bei mir auf dem 3D-Drucker hier oben drauf.
Der übrigens so gar nicht mehr aussieht.
Ich habe mittlerweile den Raspberry Pi getauscht und einen im Gehäuse dahingestellt.
Bei mir ist, nee, WLAN ist bei mir nicht blau, also für die Access-Points, sondern auch rot, weil die Access-Points über PoE gehen.
Da hat mich übrigens der Chat auf die Idee gebracht.
Der Chat hat mich auf die Idee gebracht.
Ich habe einfach ein 48-Volt-Netzteil an den Switch angeschlossen.
Und kann jetzt ordentlich auf die Idee gehen.
Ich habe da unten drunter so ein Klebeding gemacht
und jetzt pappt es oben drauf.
Es gibt hinter der AJ-Buchse
vier Pins, die gehen an das Head.
Ah, okay, das ergibt
natürlich schon Sinn. Das wäre ein Werkzeug,
ja. Das ist wahrscheinlich das teuerste
an dem ganzen Werkzeugschrank.
Das wäre ein Werkzeug.
Na, wobei,
die 3D-Drucker-Rack
und das, was drin ist, waren jetzt gerade...
Nee, ist es nicht. Der Switch alleine kostet
ja schon 550 Euro.
Aber der Maul-Schlüssel-Satz,
so geil er zu benutzen ist,
so selten braucht man ihn, wenn man nicht gerade
irgendwie Automechaniker ist,
ist eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt,
viel zu teuer.
Ich weiß nicht,
was mich da geritten hat,
warum ich mir den Maul-Schlüssel-Satz gekauft habe.
Ich meine,
wäre Joker
Set...
Ich meine,
173 Euro.
Das ist wirklich MonkaS, Alter.
Die gibt es übrigens noch teurer.
Die gibt es übrigens noch teurer, ne?
Es gibt noch die abgewinkelte Variante.
Ähm...
Das ist, glaube ich, die abgewinkelte Variante.
Die kostet 234.
Noch teurer.
Also, wie...
Das Coole an denen ist, also,
Vera hat auch noch die normalen,
die ohne Ratsche.
Die sind ein bisschen günstiger.
Gibt es die überhaupt noch?
Gab es nicht auch welche ohne Ratsche?
Wie dem auch sei,
das ist das Set, was ich mir...
Das ist echt nice.
Also, das macht ultra Bock damit, was zu schrauben.
Ich musste letztens beispielsweise
den Tisch wieder festschrauben, wo ich
hier meine, meine, meine
Lötmatte drauf habe und wo ich auch
im Stream schon von gestreamt habe.
Also, dieser Tisch mit der Kamera oben drüber und dem Ring-Light.
Der hat sich ein bisschen verzogen,
weil er die ganze Zeit an der Heizung stand
und ist halt ein bisschen lockerer geworden.
Ich hätte mir übelst einen abgebrochen,
hätte ich da unter dem Tisch, da drüben,
mit normalen Maulschlüsseln,
schlüsseln müssen. Und hier die Ratsche
aufgesetzt.
20 Sekunden eine Seite, 20 Sekunden
andere Seite. Innerhalb von 2 Minuten
war das Ding wieder bombenfest.
Also, echt, echt huge, das Set.
Echt geil.
Tja, und warum ich das hier so hingehängt habe,
ist ganz einfach. Hat zwei Gründe. Erstens,
kommt man hier schön einfach dran,
zum rausziehen. Und zweitens, kann man damit gut posen.
Das ist natürlich auch ein wichtiger Punkt,
wenn man so teures Werkzeug hat.
So, mal schnell durchscrollen.
Okay, was er da genau vorhat,
ich check's absolut nicht,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall optisch schon mal
nicht schlecht.
Max, wo schaust du nach,
ob sie Steckdosen flashen lassen
und welche nicht? Also, die beste
Tasmota-Datenbank ist...
Database...
Blackadder oder wie das? Das da?
Das ist so mit
die beste Datenbank, wo du
nachgucken kannst, ähm,
auch die Settings für die Geräte.
Also, wenn ich zum Beispiel mal das Ding jetzt raus,
was ich letztens, was wir zusammen
im Stream geflasht haben, das war das hier.
Ich glaube zumindest, dass wir das im Stream gemacht haben.
Ähm, so.
Dann siehst du hier, okay, das lässt sich prinzipiell
flashen und sonst was, aber,
das ist halt nur eine Momentaufnahme.
Das hat mal irgendwann einer gekauft und geflasht.
Das heißt nicht,
dass sich das aktuell noch flashen lässt.
Bei manchen,
bei manchen haben sie den Hinweis drin,
wenn sich einer beschwert hat, dass es nicht mehr geht,
dass, ähm,
ein Hinweis, dass es jetzt nicht mehr so sein könnte.
Ansonsten hast du echt ein Problem.
Es gibt keine wirklich aktuelle Quelle,
weil sich das permanent
ändern kann, je nachdem
Firmwarestand der, der Hardware, ja.
Was halt tatsächlich
bisschen doof
ist, ne. Was, was
du machen kannst, ist mal angenommen, du suchst auf Amazon,
ja, gehst mal wieder Amazon...
So, gehen wir mal über Amazon,
suchen das Teil...
Ja, das hier zum Beispiel
geht's bei Amazon rein.
Ich mach mal kurz, äh,
Flashbang.
Du kannst hier suchen nach, äh,
du kannst suchen nach Tuya, einmal ist
nicht schlecht.
Und nach Tasmota.
So, und da siehst du schon,
neue Firmware Tasmota OTA
geht nicht. Tja.
Da siehst du,
es ist aktuell nicht mehr möglich, die zu
flashen. Hier Mitte des Jahres
ging's noch, letzte, Ende letzten Jahres
ging's nicht mehr. Allerdings, die letzte
Chance, die du hast.
Was es bringt, so was zu flashen, zum
Beispiel,
dass ich eine Steckdosenleiste über das Webinterface steuern kann.
Die hier ist zum Beispiel für einen 3D-Drucker.
Kann ich meinen 3D-Drucker
Remote anschalten und sie sogar in den Strom
verbraucht. By the way, dieses Webinterface
ist nur ein Teil. Ich hab's in meiner, ich hab's in
meiner Heimautomatisierung drinne.
In meiner Heimautomatisierung drinne,
dass ich das Ganze machen kann.
Excellent.
Sieht bei mir aktuell so aus. Ich hoffe, ich
kann euch das mal zeigen, ohne dass ich
was leake.
Excellent.
Ups. Jawoll.
So sieht das aktuell aus.
Das ist, das ist das, die, die Karte
für, ähm, das ist übrigens
meine, mein, mein, mein
Test Home Assistant. Ich hab
HA und, und HO. HO ist das
Teste, Testing Ding.
Und so sieht das aktuell aus. Das heißt, sprich, hier
kann ich jetzt, also sprich, das hier,
dieser Schalter ist der
eigentliche von, von dieser Steckdose.
Äh, kann ich meinen 3D-Drucker
an- und ausschalten. Hier hab ich noch auf meinem Schreibtisch
die ganzen Stecker. Steckdosenleiste.
Hier ist der Switch angeschlossen. Hier kann ich
USB an- und ausmachen. Hier hab ich noch eine Steckdose
am, an der Eingangstür.
Dann hab ich noch drei freie
auf dem Schreibtisch. Eins, zwei, drei.
Hab ich durchgelabelt. Das ist, äh,
RGB-Fensterbeleuchtung.
RGB an der Decke. Hier muss
übrigens noch das Ring-Light rein. Das Ring-Light fehlt noch,
was neben mir hängt. Und hier kann ich noch die Heizung
einstellen.
So. Ja, und zum Flashen, was auch noch nice
ist, man kann zum Beispiel auch so Sachen wie seinen
Staubsauger flashen und dann bekommt man ein Webinterface
von seinem Staubsauger. Ich könnte
jetzt den Staubsauger da hinschicken, wenn ich da hinklicke,
aber will ich nicht. So. Verwirrt die Katz.
Excellent.
Ja, Kelmore, leider,
leider nicht, ne. Jetzt hab ich auch,
auf die hab ich auch ein Auge geworfen.
Offline nur über WLAN. Korrekt, du brauchst keine Cloud
mehr. Ja, und wie gesagt, hier, hiermit kann ich
jetzt meinen 3D-Drucker ein- und ausschalten. Deswegen lohnt sich das
zu flashen, ja.
Du kannst damit auch automatisch die Dosen
fernsteuern, ja. Kannst du machen.
Das kannst du machen.
Kannst Zeit steuern,
nach Sonnenaufgang steuern, nach
äh, anderen Events steuern, alles, was du steuern
willst. Wie geht das mit der Heizung?
Äh, ich hatte
die ganze Zeit so ein Zigbee-Thermostat,
die waren aber kacke.
Ich hab ein bisschen mit den Dingern rumexperimentiert,
die sacken aber. Und jetzt hab ich,
hab ich tatsächlich die rote
Pest aus Berlin am Start.
Äh, an den Heizungen,
hier hab ich, ähm, aber nicht an allen
im ganzen Haus, nur da, wo ich's regeln will.
Da hab ich tatsächlich Fritz, Fritz
Dinger. Die funktionieren bisher
echt ziemlich gut, muss ich
sagen. Die haben nur einen Nachteil,
ähm, die haben nur einen,
einen großen Nachteil.
Die sind ein bisschen langsam, was das Schalten
angeht. Was nicht so schlimm ist für
ein Thermostat, ja. Ob
das jetzt 5 Minuten früher oder später angeht, ist egal.
Aber zum Strom sparen
rufen die sich den Standplus alle 15 Minuten
mal ab. Man kann allerdings hier
jedes, man kann mit dem Drücken auf
OK das jedes Mal triggern.
Also die haben einen Delay von 15, von maximal
15 Minuten, je nachdem.
Nein, die hab ich nicht mit das Motor geflasht.
Die sind Standard, äh, Standard Firmware, aber
die Standard Firmware ist OK und
äh, braucht keine Cloud oder sonst was und
lässt sich in Home Assistant einbinden.
Ja. Das nächste ist eine
sehr gute Frage.
Wie hast du eigentlich Local HTTPS geregelt?
Self Sign? Nee, weder noch.
Äh, Cloudflare DNS?
Let's Encrypt?
DNS Challenge?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hab die Steckdosen, aber nicht
kaufen, nicht kaufen, ne. Ich hab die hier.
Unter anderem. Ich hab, ich hab
total viele verschiedenen, weil ich
immer gucke, ob man die grad flashen kann.
Ob man die grad flashen kann.
Das hängt
ganz entscheidend davon ab,
welchen Stand
die Steckdosen haben,
wenn sie ausgeliefert werden.
Also als ich mir die gekauft hab, konnte man sie
noch flashen.
Ähm, Moment, Moment, ich erzähl
Mist. Das stimmt gar nicht.
Die konnte man auch nicht flashen.
Die musste ich ja aufschrauben.
Leute, stimmt nicht. Die Sachen, die ich
flashen konnte, waren die anderen.
Flashchamp.org
Die musste ich
aufschrauben.
Die musste ich aufschrauben, genau.
Da hab ich ne Anleitung gefunden. Irgendwo
irgendeine niederländische Anleitung.
Äh.
Das da.
Kann's glaub ich sein.
Genau, da hab ich ne Anleitung gefunden, welche Pins
was sind.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Die musste ich flashen über
hier. Über Tims.
Nein, das waren nicht die,
die ich aufgebrochen hab.
Die, die ich aufgebrochen hab im Stream, waren die
doppelten.
Die, die ich im Stream aufgebrochen hab, waren die
gosundsp, ich glaub die da.
Die hab ich im Stream
aufgebrochen. Die doppelten.
Die da.
Wobei sich die
hätten theoretisch eigentlich noch flashen
lassen müssen. Aber die hier haben sich auch
nicht flashen lassen, deswegen. Die musste ich aufmachen.
Das war auch ein ganz schöner Akt.
Da musste man hier neben mit dem Schraubendreher
sehr sehr ordentlich
hebeln, dass man die aufbekommt. Also
komplett ohne Rückstände
am Gehäuse ging's nicht. Also meine
haben jetzt an der Seite hier überall so ne kleine
Delle, wo ich die aufgehebelt hab.
Und
ähm. Im Prinzip hab ich's genauso
gemacht wie in der Anleitung. Also sprich ich hab's aufgemacht.
Hab äh.
An die Pins
meinen Flasher dran gelötet.
Also Flasher, man braucht
so nen äh.
FTDI
So was da in der Richtung
braucht man.
Oh die muss man anschließen dann
an den Rechner und dann kann man vom Computer oder
Raspberry Pi aus flashen. Also sprich
man lötet hier die Kabel an.
Am besten ein paar Jumperkabel, die man einfach wieder
abmachen kann oder man nimmt so welche
die man hier reinstecken kann.
Und äh dann
schließt man
das an Raspberry Pi an und flasht das Motor drauf.
Ist ein bisschen größerer Akt, aber ich kann euch
sagen, wenn ihr es mal gemacht habt
das geht
wenn man ein bisschen Übung hat
relativ schnell. Also wenn ihr
wenn ihr euch keine Ahnung angenommen, ihr kauft euch
ein 8er, packt Steckdosen
und äh bei den ersten braucht ihr
ne halbe Stunde pro Steckdose
und zum Schluss
braucht ihr ne Viertelstunde mit ein bisschen Übung.
Viertelstunde pro Steckdose.
Aber besser ist es natürlich
sie lassen sich flashen übers WLAN
und das hängt halt ganz entscheidend
von der
von der firmware Version ab. Und die hier
waren zu neu, die konnte ich nicht mehr übers WLAN flashen.
Es gibt auf Github dieses
dieses Projekt
damit kann man versuchen mit nem Raspberry Pi
übers WLAN die Steckdosen zu
zu flashen. Die machen das ganz trickreich
die geben sich irgendwie
die machen nen WLAN auf, was so heißt wie das WLAN
wo die Steckdosen initial
quasi geflasht werden beim China
Hersteller und dann machen sie komische
Dinger und überlisten
die Steckdosen mit alter firmware
dass sie denken sie werden
gerade vom Hersteller geflasht.
Das funktioniert
allerdings
halt nicht
bei allem. Wir können mal die neuen Releases gucken
ob es da was neues gibt.
Jetzt ist das erste Release.
Ja also ihr seht die Leute haben auch noch ganz schön Probleme
aber damit
damit musst du nicht mehr aufschrauben
damit kannst du übers WLAN flashen
das ist dann relativ einfach
ähm
ja genau
es ist halt ein bisschen Glück
ob es drauf ankommt, also ob es klappt
ähm
ne
die flashen
wenn du die aufschraubst und kommst an die Pins dran
dann kannst du gleich direkt die Software flashen
die du flashen willst
ne ne
du musst halt aufschrauben, dann kannst du auch direkt flashen
leider
geht es halt nicht mehr bei allen Geräten
deswegen gucke ich immer vorher bei Amazon lässt sich das flashen
und hier ist es anscheinend so
und hier schreiben ja auch viele bei Amazon
dass das nicht mehr geht
wenn man hier sucht
wie gesagt Tuya suchen oder Tasmota suchen
und dann sieht man das es nicht funktioniert
hier sieht man mal wie das die Chinesen nicht checken
was der Typ gefragt hat
warum kommt dann kein Hersteller auf die Idee
sowas ohne Cloud zu machen, gibt es
zum Beispiel von Shelly
Shelly hat den dümmsten
Domain Name
shelly.cloud
ein hauptsächliches Feature der Geräte von Shelly ist
dass sie keine Cloud brauchen
das ist unglaublich dumm
ich weiß nicht warum man sich so eine bescheuerte Domain macht
also eines der Hauptverkaufsargumente ist
dass es ohne Cloud geht
also die haben sowas
das ist halt teurer als der China Kram
die haben noch mehr
die haben auch kleine
ja das ist halt ein bisschen teurer
du guck mal hier
diese Dosen bekommst du und die gibt es auch teilweise nicht
hier bekommst du
4 Dosen für 36 Euro
und wenn man es aus China Land bestellt
also 9 Euro pro Dose
so ein Shelly Plug
kostet
22 Euro
kriegt man vielleicht auch ein bisschen besser
im Shelly Shop
aber das ist halt
der preisliche Unterschied
die sind einfach billiger
die China Dinger
und wenn die sich flashen lassen ist richtig nice
naja also du bezahlst ungefähr das doppelte
für so ein Shelly Ding
es gibt noch mehr Hersteller die es ohne Cloud machen
aber Shelly ist somit das bekannteste
es gibt aber
die China Dinger sind halt so beliebt
weil im Prinzip die gleiche Hardware drin ist
wie bei den Shellys also an Controller
aber halt
sie nur die Hälfte kosten
deswegen war das auch so geil
die zu flashen die China Teile
genau so sieht es aus
Shelly geht komplett offline
WLAN gut ist
und die China Dinger
gehen nach dem Flaschen ja auch komplett offline
wie gesagt ich kann hier
ich habe es euch ja gezeigt
ich kann hier über das Web Interface
oder über meine Heimautomatisierung
schalten
ja
na gut
das habe ich übersehen
Moin welches Audio Interface Mixer kannst du für das MMX
äh
keinen
weil ich habe es an meinem Audio Interface dran
das ist eigentlich zu teuer um es so zu empfehlen
weil ich habe mir das Audio Interface damals gekauft
weil ich da noch viel mehr dran angeschlossen habe
ich habe meine zwei PCs dran angeschlossen
ich habe die Konsole dran angeschlossen
ich habe die ganzen Mikrofons dran angeschlossen
Mikrofone
ich habe das da
die haben ein neues
da ist es halt mal her
oh das ist die Rack Bauweise
also ich habe das da
äh hallo
das habe ich mir schon vor
Jahren gekauft
das da genau
das Teil
das kommt mit so einem Breakout Kabel
da hast du alle möglichen Anschlüsse
du hast mehrere Kopfhörer Ausgänge
ein Mikrofon ein Ausgänge
also es ist wirklich top
lohnt sich aber nicht
weil es ist eigentlich viel zu teuer
wenn du einfach nur das MMX 300 anschließen willst
ähm
was viele Leute empfehlen
für PC
wenn du quasi
einfach nur
einen MMX qualitativ hochwertigen Audio Ausgang
für den PC haben willst
sind diese Fiu Dinger
habe ich persönlich aber noch nie ausprobiert
die Dinger werden aber oftmals in Audio Foren empfohlen
dass sie ganz gut sein sollen
zeigen die Jelly Plugs auch den Stromverbrauch
ja wenn du den richtigen Jelly Plug nimmst
äh Shop
die haben verschiedene
die haben äh
Products
äh Relays Plug and Play
äh genau ich glaube der kann auch den Stromverbrauch
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine
die sind halt mega hässlich
ich glaube der hier kann auch den Stromverbrauch
die haben auch viele Sachen
die sind relativ
äh
die braucht man nicht unbedingt
aber die haben ganz gute Sachen
ja das hier würde ich mit billig
guck mal hier
einen Jelly Door Sensor kostet was
ja
oh meine Güte
äh
16 Euro
ja
der kann glaube ich auch Strom messen
also nicht Strom messen äh äh Verbrauch
ja Power Metering
wobei es ja
gar keinen Verbrauch in dem Sinn gibt
das wird ja alles umgewandelt
wird uns jetzt der Physiker sagen
Energieerhaltung ja
und gerade so ein 3D Drucker
wandelt auch ganz äh äh
wandelt recht viel um in der Raum wird warm
ja
also kannst du auch kannst du machen
Hacky genau so Sachen
finde ich immer richtig gut
das ist ein richtig gutes Beispiel für wenn
wenn Leute Hacky schreibt hier
der Plug S hängt bei ihm an der Waschmaschine
und schickt ihm eine Nachricht wenn es fertig ist
das ist genau das was ich immer sage
wo es beim Thema Heimautomatisierung drum geht
es geht nicht darum irgendwie
50 Geräte anzuschließen
dass man dann ein cooles Dashboard hat
äh um
regelmäßig auf sein Tablet zu gucken
und nie was zu verwenden
worum es zumindest meiner Meinung nach bei Heimautomatisierung
geht ist Dinge
die man immer wieder macht
und die einen nerven
oder sagen wir mal Dinger wo man relativ easy
am Anfang durch kleinen
kleine Investitionen
schon viel Komfort für sich rausholen kann
das ist das Wichtige
also sprich mal angenommen man hat die Waschmaschine
irgendwo im Hof stehen in der Garage
gibt es ja Leute ähm
und ihr wollt mitbekommen wann die fertig ist
schließt ihr einen Shelly Plug an der den Strom misst
oder den Verbrauch misst
oder wie auch immer der korrekte Bezeichnung dafür ist
und lasst euch eine Nachricht schicken
die dann fertig ist
sowas bringt dann richtig was und es ist auch ein Mehrwert
ähm
und jetzt nicht irgendwelche RGB
Beleuchtung
weil RGB Beleuchtung
RGB Beleuchtung ist der
ist das überschätzteste
Heimautomatisierungs
ähm Produktkategorie
überhaupt RGB Beleuchtung
braucht 95%
der Leute nicht
es ist komplett sinnlos
in 95% der Anwendungsfälle
braucht man RGB Beleuchtung
außer in den ganz seltenen Fällen
wo eine RGB Beleuchtung tatsächlich sinnvoll ist
die normale Beleuchtung von einem Raum
reicht vollkommen aus
wenn es eine Lampe ist
die man an und ausschalten kann
das kann man übrigens mit so einem Shelly Relay
wunderbar machen
also
90% der Fälle
reicht das aus wenn man einfach nur
an und ausschalten kann die Lampe die schon da ist
zum Beispiel mit so einem Shelly Relay
easy
der nächste Punkt ist
wenn man wirklich
Lampen
steuern will
in den nächsten 95% der Fälle
reicht wenn die Lampe dimmbar ist
dass man damit das machen kann
was man will
wenn man zum Beispiel im Wohnzimmer möchte das das Licht
bisschen dunkler wird
wenn man den Film anschaltet dann braucht man
eine dimmbare Lampe
ist deutlich deutlich günstiger
als eine RGB Lampe
zum Beispiel das ist der Hersteller von dem ich mein
wenn du dir die Sachen einfach nur
dimmbar kaufst
dann kostet es einfach die Hälfte von dem normalen
so der nächste Schritt ist
nach dimmbar ist
mit
ich nenn es mal so weiß Angleich
da kann man dann beispielsweise einstellen
wie weiß weiß
ist also sprich wie rötlich
oder blau oder das ganze ist
der Vorteil ist
ist auch nochmal die Farbtemperatur
ist auch nochmal billiger
weil du brauchst
also dimmbar brauchst du eine LED
eine weiße
eine weiße LED brauchst du dimmbar
so für
Angleich
Temperatur Angleich
also Temperaturauswahl bei der Lampe
brauchst du eine weiße LED
und wahrscheinlich
mindestens noch eine rote LED
wenn die
weiße LED relativ
bläulich hell ist
so da brauchst du nur zwei
RGB brauchst du halt vier
LEDs deswegen kosten die
auch mehr du brauchst eine weiße
du brauchst eine rote du brauchst
eine grüne und eine blaue
so und deswegen
ist meiner Meinung nach RGB das überschätzteste
Ding die meisten Leute hängen sich
RGB hin verwenden
aber zu 95%
maximal dimmbar und vielleicht
Farbtemperatur
ja und
deswegen alles mit RGB
auszustatten
was ist gelb nicht grün
was
natürlich grün
gelb
wie kommst du auf gelb
das ist englisch
das ist red green blue
und ich yellow blue
jebaited alter
ähm
äh
brauchst du bei RGB nicht nur drei
doch theoretisch schon
aber weiß sieht mit RGB bei Lampen nicht gut aus
das beste ist
also
rot grün blau weiß
nur so kriegst du auch einen ordentlichen
Weißton hin
für sowas ist es sinnvoll
da hast du recht aber
wahrscheinlich hast du halt
von ich sag jetzt einfach mal 20 Lampen
oder so hast du wahrscheinlich
ähm 2
wo du das RGB Feature oder so verwendest
also zu 95%
brauchen die Leute
dort wo sie RGB Lampen
haben höchstens dimmbar
meiner Einschätzung nach
vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr
mal ein bisschen weniger
aber wenn man sein Haus mit smarter Beleuchtung versorgen will
ist das das beste was man am Anfang machen kann
äh das einfach sich ein Relay zu holen
und die bestehenden Lampen zu verwenden
und das nächste ist dann
was zu holen was dimmbar ist
und eventuell die Farbtemperatur einstellen kann
man spart unglaublich viel Geld dadurch
ja auch
ähm weil die Leute hingehen und sagen
oh ich will Smart Lighting Smart Lighting
und kaufen sich einfach mal 20 30
da bist du ja da bist du ja schon mal
was weiß ich 1000 Euro los
so und
kaufst du und kaufst du nur
kaufst du einfach nur dimmbare
dann kostet sich nur 300 Euro
äh wenn du mietest kannst du nicht einfach
Relays bauen by the way
ich würde das sogar in der Mietwohnung machen
weil du kannst es ja wieder ausbauen
das ist ja nix
äh zerstört ja nix
aber ja kann ich verstehen wenn man das nicht will
man muss ja nix kaputt machen
wenn man die Relays einbaut
ja man macht äh man macht den den
den Rahmen ab von der
also man macht erstmal
die Sicherung raus ja
und man guckt sich Tutorials an wie es geht
und wenn man keine Ahnung hat lasst man es in den Leckträger machen
genau die Taster
gehen mit Shelly weiterhin das ist ja gerade der Sinn dahinter
also du kannst ja quasi
du kannst ja den Schalter weiter benutzen
und äh trotzdem
über deine Heimautomatisierung ein- und ausschalten
es gibt
es gibt die Shell es gibt diese Shell
und es gibt noch die Shell
die die weniger Anschlüsse brauchen
frag mich bin ich der große Elektro Elektro Pro
ja genau
äh Easy Light das beste ist
man macht Lampen
und Relays
weil
weil weil weil
weil die Sache ist die
solange die Lichtschalter noch funktionieren
gibt es Leute die benutzen die Lichtschalter
und wenn du den Lichtschalter ausmachst
kannst du deine RGB Lampe nicht mehr einschalten
weil es ja der Strom aus ist
wenn man es wirklich richtig richtig
gescheit machen will
müsstest du entweder deine Lichtschalter
äh austauschen gegen welche die deine Lampe
ein- und ausschalten können nur über WLAN
oder aber
du würdest
dir das immer wieder kaputt machen also
die beste Kombination ist wirklich
du hast ein Relay und an den Stellen wo du es brauchst
noch trotz Licht dimmbar die Lampe
weil dann kannst du es über den Schalter
ein- und ausschalten
dann musst du deine RGB Lampen so einschalten
dass die letzte was eingestellt war
wieder neu anmachen
und das können alle RGB Lampe
und dann
kannst du es so machen du
steuerst das also du kannst ein- und ausschalten
nach wie vor über den Schalter
und wenn du es dann eingeschaltet hast
und möchtest die Farbtemperatur
oder sonst was ändern das musst du dann halt über das Web Interface machen
oder über die App oder was auch immer
du verwendest oder du nimmst
noch einen weiteren Schalter
gibt es ja mittlerweile welche die man auch magnetisch
irgendwohin hängen kann für für
umschalten der Lampen
es gibt Milliarden Varianten wie man das machen kann
es ist wirklich unzählbar
wie man das machen kann
das ist auch das wichtigste und warum ich denke dass
wenn man im Thema Heimautomatisierung
was macht warum fertige
Lösungen nichts bringen
weil das echt
total individuell ist
wie man es am liebsten hat und wenn man eine fertige Lösung hat
dann kriegt man 80%
hin aber man wird nie es wirklich
optimal für sich hinbekommen
weil das die fertigen Lösungen einfach nicht bieten
wenn man wenn man das selbst macht
dann hast du noch zusätzlich den Vorteil
du kannst es genauso machen wie du willst
oder wie es deine Frau will Freundin wollen
du kannst für die Kinder richtig einstellen
und du hast den Vorteil
du bist nicht herstellergebunden
du kannst wenn du sowas wie Home Assistant verwendest
du kannst mehr oder weniger
alle Geräte
miteinander kombinieren
du musst es nicht nur von einem Hersteller machen
nicht nur mit einer Funktechnologie
es bietet sich natürlich an Sachen zu nehmen
die auf ähnlicher Technologie basieren
dass man jetzt nicht 50 Sticks braucht
aber es würde gehen
ich habe es bei mir auch mittlerweile so
es ist ja über die Zeit gewachsen
ich habe Sachen über WLAN drin
ich habe Sachen über Zigbee drin
ich habe Sachen über Z-Wave drin
ich habe Sachen über DECT drin
über ganz normale Netzwerkkabel
und
über klassischen
Funk auf 433
Megahertz nämlich für die
Rollläden
alles integriert im Home Assistant
und funktioniert zusammen
was du so bei einer fertigen Lösung im Leben nicht hinkriegst
ja
excellent
äh V-Mysterion leider nicht
ich habe den hier
aber ich habe keine Ahnung ob der noch angesagt ist
der liegt nämlich so in dem Preis
aber ich glaube der ist alt mittlerweile
ich habe mir den ja auch vor 2 Jahren oder so gekauft
äh doch bestimmt
musste mal suchen
also
ich bin ja kein Fan von AliExpress
für 230 Volt
Geräte allerdings
wenn man diese Dinger sich kauft von Amazon
kann man sich die auch von AliExpress kaufen
weil im Ernst das ist der gleiche Crap
also ob man diese
Dinger sich bei AliExpress bestellt oder bei Amazon
macht ja im Endeffekt keinen Unterschied
ähm die haben
CE Zeichen aber die sind wahrscheinlich
ohne zu testen aufgedruckt wie bei dem ganzen China Kram
das ist ja auch so ein Ding was man
sich selbst verleihen kann irgendwie ich glaube CE Zeichen
sagt ja nicht wirklich irgendwas aus
also
wie gesagt ich bin ja kein großer Fan
von AliExpress für 230 Volt
Geräte aber die Dinger habe ich trotzdem und funktionieren gut
wenn du es ein bisschen sicherer haben willst
nimm dir den Shelly Plug
das ist zwar auch
äh
China Chip aber ich hoffe mal
ein bisschen besser Qualität kontrolliert
so ich weiß gar nicht
wie viel kosten so ein Shelly Plug
aktuell
ja der kleine
was soll das
jetzt mal ernsthaft
warum ist der Kokona Plug kostet nur die Hälfte
es sieht kacke aus
ja optisch ist der hier schon
am besten aber
ok was kostet ein 4er Pack Shelly
64 Euro
es geht
ich mein man muss sich mal überlegen
hier kostet der
4er Pack
64 Euro bei Amazon kostet halt
36 Euro für die China Dinger
also es ist schon nicht ganz die Hälfte
aber es ist halt schon ein Unterschied und
die kriegt man im Angebot bei Amazon teilweise
noch günstiger
kann man sich
nehmen was man lustig ist
aber warum kostet
der Kokona Plug so wenig
es sieht
hässlich aus ja ok
er kann auch 230 Volt ok
warum ist er so viel
billiger
kann man RGB bei den Shelly Stecker
steuern
du meinst was das für eine Farbe hat hier innen
keine Ahnung ich habe einen Shelly
Stecker aber der liegt in der Box
die hier kommen mit Tasmota vom Werk
heh sieht fast so aus
wie meine
echt
wo kann man die kaufen
AliExpress
guck mal die Chinesen
die Chinesen liefern schon den Kram direkt mit aus
exzellent
die Chinesen
ok 4 Stück
kostet 43 Euro
ok
die Chinesen liefern schon den Kram direkt mit aus
das ist doch schon mal ganz gut
achja Shipping Standard Shipping
das geht bestimmt über EU Warenlage
das es nicht beim Zoll hängen bleibt
finde ich interessant
dass die das schon Preflashed haben
finde ich cool
kannte ich jetzt noch nicht
du kannst ja danach einfach drüber flashen
dann ist Ruhe
das finde ich cool
gibt es die auch bei
da müssen wir jetzt mal kurz gucken
gibt es die auch bei Banggood
die haben oftmals sogar noch ein Ticken billiger
darf ich mal fragen
was du mit dem Server so machst
bin auf dich geschossen
ja kann ich dir sagen
ich schlage nur kurz nach der Steckdose
suchen
Blitzwolf
das ist das typische China Ding
hier da
ist da auch schon das
Zigbee WTF
ja also was mache ich mit meinem Server
du sprichst von diesem Teil da unten
also lass mal überlegen was habe ich denn auf dem Server alles
drauf
ich habe meine Heimautomatisierung drauf
mit Home Assistant
ich habe ein Wiki drauf
ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken
ich habe so ein Dashboard drauf
was ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht brauche
ich habe
einen PXE Server drauf
ich
habe
mein Git Web
Frontend Zeug drauf
ich habe einen Fileserver drauf
äh
ich habe so 10 Sachen
oder so drauf ungefähr
eine Datenbank
wo ich meine ganze Hardware habe
habe ich drauf
trägst du in das Wiki wirklich was ein
ja in dem Wiki steht
zum Beispiel drinnen wie ich das mit
Certbot Let's Encrypt mache
wie ich Tasmota MQTT
für Home Assistant einrichte und sowas
ja da schreibe ich wirklich manchmal Sachen rein
ähm
ah ja Shit meine ich
Shit Shit
welches Wiki Doku Wiki
äh was habe ich denn da noch drauf
achso ja ich habe noch
eine Pains Jam Nextcloud drauf
aber das suckt ich bin überhaupt kein Nextcloud Fan
ähm
es ist alles
über Docker Compose
bis auf meine Heimautomatisierung
die habe ich umgezogen
in eine VM
weil die das Docker Setup nicht mehr richtig supportet haben
habe ich gedacht scheiß drauf zieh sie in eine VM um
und seitdem funktioniert es ohne Probleme
hat auch noch einen weiteren großen Vorteil
wenn ich ein Update mache
mache ich einfach vorher einen VM Snapshot
was für eine Hardware
oh sowas super billiges
äh S-Rock
J41
sowas sowas hier in der Richtung
nicht exakt das aber fast das
ja und
der Kram kostet auch nicht viel
80 Euro kostet das Board
oder noch billiger
das Board habe ich hier
aber aber nicht oh das ist die neue Variante
aber ich habe das Board nur eine
Generation älter
mit dem mit dem langen PCI Express
weil ich habe es so gemacht
in dem PCI Express ist eine 10G
ist eine 10G Netzwerkkarte drin
äh man kann sie nicht ganz mit
10 Gigabit ansprechen weil
ähm der Board selbst nur
zweifach angeboten ist
ja und das ist tatsächlich ein LTP Drucker Board
ja
echt oldschool
so also habe ich irgendwas übersehen
aber das ist interessant
dass die
dass die Standardmärkte mit Tasmota kommen
das finde ich echt cool
was ja im Endeffekt heißt
also
Moment
ich gehe gerade noch mal kurz auf AliExpress
das heißt ich würde hier
erstmal kurz überlegen
also ich würde hier einen 4er Pack kriegen
hä jetzt kostet es auf einmal wieder mehr
ach ne das ist hier
der 4er Pack
ach Moment deutsch US Dollar
ne ne Währung Euro
guck mal die kommen sogar aus
Frankreich dann hast du sogar den Versand
sogar der Versand geht schnell
was ist das
6 Stück
6 Stück ey das ist sogar relativ
hey das geht ey das ist preislich
gar nicht mal so schlecht
guck mal du kriegst die vorinstallierte
China Steckdose zum Preis
von der die du selbst flashen müsstest
und die du aufmachen musst
und nicht flashen kannst
hey das ist gar nicht mal so übel
den 6er Pack den finde ich eigentlich recht
recht sinnvoll
warum ist das jetzt auf einmal wieder
US Dollar ich habe doch
hä
warum ist das US Dollar ich habe umgestellt auf Euro
ach guck mal der ist sogar
im Angebot gerade
hä
ich check es nicht
ach die sind gerade im Angebot ok
hey das ist preislich echt nicht übel
also würde ich Steckdosen brauchen
ich würde mir jetzt den 6er Pack bestellen
können die Power Meter
wahrscheinlich nicht oder
das sind die billigen
Steckdosen Champ
ja die offizielle App braucht kein Mensch
also das wird dann darüber Tasmota gesteuert
Moment sind die überhaupt schon
vorinstalliert
ach ne Moment das sind andere die
vorinstalliert sind
das hier waren gar nicht die mit Tasmota
Alter das ist ja Verwirrung pur
Chinesen wieder am Start
haha
können die
gucken wie viel die Geräte verbrauchen dahinter
weil das finde ich immer ganz nützlich
sie haben zu kalibrieren
Energie Meter
ok das ist cool
hier steht kein Tasmota drin
aber das ist
ernsthaft das würde ich mir wahrscheinlich sogar holen
Rutsch durch 4
ja
das würde ich mir wahrscheinlich sogar holen
also das klingt vorinstalliertes Tasmota
würde ich gleich das neueste drüber flashen und gut ist
finde ich
ist eigentlich eine ganz coole Geschichte
und wenn man Glück hat kommt das
manche kamen aus Frankreich stand da
manche kommen aus Frankreich
oder was auch immer
ach man weiß es nicht
Voraussichtliche Lieferung 11. April
ok das ist halt
das ist halt das Ding wenn man in China
bestellt ne
aber interessant gut zu wissen das es das gibt
finde ich nice
ja man kann sich auch ein Shelly kaufen
dann bezahlt es dann ungefähr
40% mehr muss man
sich jeder selbst überlegen
das stimmt
Motu hat den besten Namen
der Shelly Doorsensor sieht scheiße aus
ja die Doorsensor sehen meistens
kacke aus
ich hab
Z-Wave Doorsensor
Fenstersensor gekauft
bei AliExpress für glaube
7,57 das Stück als es mal im Angebot war
für 60% reduziert
davon habe ich mir einen kleinen 20er Pack gekauft
ich habe immer noch welche hier rumfliegen
Auskennfuchs 19 Monate Subscription
Dankeschön für den Sub
äh ich weiß gar nicht was das Shelly 4 Pro ist
ehrlich gesagt
ich blick nämlich bei den
bei den Shelly Produkten nicht mehr durch
Shelly 4
ach das ist auf auf den Leiste
boah ne keine Ahnung
genau also Farbtemperatur
ist nice richtig RGB brauchen
eigentlich die wenigsten
der Auskennfuchs kennt sich mal wieder aus
hat er recht
ne?
der Drucker mischt
die Lampen scheinen selbst
deswegen funktioniert das anders
also
Subtraktiv heißt das was der Drucker macht
es fällt Licht
auf das Blatt drauf
die Tinte
absorbiert Teile von dem Licht
und das was zurück kommt
ist die Farben die ihr sehen wollt
die der Drucker ausdruckt
Additiv ist das was der Monitor oder die Lampe macht
die leuchten selbst
in den Farben und das mischt sich zusammen
Big Brainstream wieder
ah yes
du hast die
die kleinen Shellys
die Einser oder welche hast du
ja die sind ganz schön fett
aber bei mir passt er auch unter die Dose
Links von den Preflashed hat doch einer gerade vorhin
in den Chat gepostet
ich find jetzt auch noch mehr
irgendeiner hat es hier irgendwo gepostet
vielleicht ist er noch da und kann es nochmal posten
China Export
Sauerei
Anzeige ist raus
Grüße an den Alex T
geb ich mal so weiter
also Alex T
Huge Gruß von
xd xd xd xd xd
hatten wir schon
kommt drauf an was du machen willst
wenn du eigene Kernel Module brauchst
dann musst du ne vor allem nehmen
ja das ist aber nicht so
easy gewesen in dem Fall
weil dieses Home Assistant Docker Setup besteht irgendwie
aus 3 oder 4 verschiedenen Containern
die du quasi zueinander passend snapshotten musst
die haben einen Supervisor Container
einen Addon Container
es ist nicht sonderlich easy gemacht
es ist in der VM tatsächlich einfacher
in der VM snapshottest du das
es werden irgendwie alle 12 Container
was die da am laufen haben gesnapshottet
machst ein Upgrade
wenn es abkackt machst du ein Revert
ansonsten lässt es laufen
also das ist in der VM definitiv einfacher
gab es wieder lustige Produkt Placement Anfragen
ja gibt es für permanent
Lord's Mobile sollte ich jetzt machen
Lord's Mobile sollte ich ein Placement machen
Instagram
Instagram Post sollte ich machen für Lord's Mobile
und ich habe überhaupt kein Instagram
auf AliExpress immer im Angebot
das stimmt teilweise aber
die Dinger wechseln tatsächlich
also diese 30% ist oftmals wirklich
zeitlich limitiert
was aber bei AliExpress
also so ist es ist immer
irgendwas davon im Angebot
also im Zweifelsfall wartest du mal 2 Wochen
dann kannst du es wieder kaufen
ich habe allein schon hier oben
ähm
Arbeitszimmer
Wohnzimmer Bad
Küche
Schlafzimmer 4
wenn ich jetzt nicht was übersehen habe
so
dann habe ich unten 2 mal Küche
Wohnzimmer
Schlafzimmer
Bad Tür
und im Keller
nochmal 4 da bist du mit den 20
schon mehr oder weniger durch ja
wenn du wirklich jedes Fenster
und Tür damit also
ich habe ja sogar nur die Außentür damit ausgestattet
die Türen im Haus überwache ich ja
gar nicht ob die auf oder zu sind wozu
das würde ich nur machen
wenn ich eine sinnvolle Automatisierung hätte
aber
habe ich bisher noch nicht gefunden
ich könnte zum Beispiel
nur mal so ein Beispiel
was mir gerade so spontan einfällt
wo man sieht was man für coole Sachen machen kann
wenn man die Sachen selbst macht und sich nicht so sehr an einen Hersteller bindet
also was ich machen könnte zum Beispiel
ich könnte an mein Klo
also an meine Badezimmertür
könnte ich
einen Türsensor hängen
so und ich könnte es jetzt
automatisierungstechnisch so programmieren
ich habe ja an der Heizung
ich weiß ja auch die Temperatur von dem Raum
und ich habe wenn ich das möchte
auch noch eine Thermostat an der Heizung
und was auch immer
also ich könnte zum Beispiel
wenn ich die Tür zum Badezimmer schließe
ähm
könnte ich im Endeffekt gucken
wie ist die Raumtemperatur
oder besser gesagt welche Jahreszeit ist es
und wie ist die Raumtemperatur
ich könnte gucken ist das Fenster auf ist das Fenster zu
wenn das Fenster geschlossen ist
und äh Raumtemperatur
unter einem gewissen Dings ist
könnte ich beispielsweise automatisch beim schließen der
Badezimmertür
ein ähm
den Heizlüfter anmachen oder sowas
oder die Heizung hochfahren lassen oder was auch immer
also man kann da schon coole Sachen machen
ja manchmal
versenden die aus Frankreich, Niederlande
Spanien und so
mach doch einfach
einen ESP2866
und Magnet
ne das bringt nix
weil du die Dinger auf Batterie laufen lassen musst
oder die
die normalen ESP2866
verbrauchen auch im Deep Sleep zu viel für Batterie
du bräuchtest dann ein extra Board
wo es dann wieder schwierig mit dem Wake Up
beim Input ist
also es tatsächlich
äh hat es seine Vorteile dort
passende Hardware zu verwenden
ey wer hat die Umfrage gemacht
ihr glaubt doch nicht
dass sie nen Instagram Account haben wollen
der 5 Follower hat
die haben schlicht und ergreifend einfach nur mal
Instagram angefragt weil jeder heute nen Instagram Account hat
außer ich anscheinend
das hat keinen Sinn Leute
Chat das ist nicht easy money
die machen das einfach nicht
hast du schon mal was von Unrate gehört
ja hab ich aber ist nicht mein Fall
ich mach die Sachen lieber selbst
keine Ahnung
hab ich noch mit diesen PCB Vorlagen
hab ich noch keine Erfahrung
hab ich noch nicht selbst gemacht
ich war mal kurz davor
ob ich mir bei PCBWay
war es glaub ich so ein eigenes Board mal designe
aber hab ich so wenig Plan von
und man hat nur so viel Zeit
wie man Zeit hat Sachen zu lernen und zu machen
was das Problem
mit diesen Smart Home Sachen ist
das kann niemand der nicht weiß wie es funktioniert
benutzen
wenn man umzieht muss man nicht
so ist doch kein großes Ding
also ich wohne im eigenen Haus
ich hab eh nicht das Problem
aber wenn ich
wenn ich noch in der alten Wohnung wohnen würde
wo ich vorher gewohnt hab
da würde ich an die wichtigsten Stellen
auch 1-2 Shelleys machen
die würde ich halt beim ausziehen wieder ausbauen
das ist ja gar kein großartiges Ding
ich hätte da keinen großartigen Bock drauf
und ich würde wahrscheinlich nicht jeden Schalter
in einer Mietwohnung mit einem Shelley versorgen
aber dort wo mich es persönlich nervt
da würde ich das trotzdem machen
wenn es nur darum geht
Geräte zu schalten würde ich einfach
einen Zwischenstecker nehmen
also man kann auch in der Mietwohnung viel machen
ja mir war klar das das gewinnt
aber ich kanns nicht ändern die werden das nicht machen Leute
da könnt ihr noch so viel voten
soviel noch soviel voten
Donaten, subscriben, giften
by the way Prime Sub
ist zurzeit
günstiger zusammen
ne also
es hat keinen Sinn
also geht nicht
der war es also
so so
Andiversum Twitch Prime Dankeschön für den Sub
nein ich mach mir keinen Instagram Account
ich hab bis heute nicht verstanden
wozu man Instagram braucht
oder du lässt die Dinge einfach drinnen
die Shelleys
und sagst keinem was
weil es schränkt ja die Funktion nicht ein
sondern es geht auch nach wie vor
ja
wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben
wollten wir nicht noch irgendwas gucken
ja
wollten wir nicht noch irgendwas anschauen
Tech Fails
lohnt sich das zu gucken
oh Tay
war das der Microsoft Nazi Bot
oder bring ichs jetzt nur durcheinander
ok wir gucken das mal
ich hab das ist ein Video was ein Mod
vorgeschlagen hat keine Ahnung
ob das was taugt aber ich denke mal
ähm war Tay
der Nazi Bot von Microsoft
also es gab mal nen Bot von Microsoft
bevor er das zeigt
ich weiß nicht ob das das war also Microsoft hat mal nen
Bot programmiert
nen Twitter Bot programmiert
der AI mäßig quasi lernen sollte
auf Fragen zu antworten
und ein paar im Zweifelsfall war es
wie der 4chan
wenn sowas passiert ist es oftmals 4chan
haben versucht den Bot zu trainieren
dass der irgendwelche antifeministischen
und Nazi Antworten gibt
also die haben den Bot quasi voll gespammt
mit irgendwie
Zeug ja
und dann hat der Bot quasi
auf die Frage was weiß ich dann hat sie
ich denke mir jetzt irgendwas aus
dann hast du den Bot gefragt zu irgendwie
was sagst du zu Frauen und dann hat der Bot gesagt
quasi äh keine Ahnung
ich hasse alle Frauen
und irgendwie
irgendwelche Nazi Sachen
der Bot
ist etwas in die Hose gegangen
von Microsoft
da wollte ich übrigens mal ein extra Video drüber machen
weil ich wollte mich damit ein bisschen mehr beschäftigen
hab mir gedacht hey wenn du dir das schon mal anguckst
kannst du auch ein Video drüber machen
hab ich aber nicht gemacht
und Microsoft hat das Ding wieder
wieder eingestellt dann nach ein paar Tagen
ok gucken wir mal
by the way
war das nicht so
ist nicht der Segway Erfinder
mit dem Segway von der Klippe gefallen
war das nicht
war da nicht irgendwas
oder ist das so eine Urban Legend
weiß gar nicht wie man das Ding schreibt
Erfinder Klippe
genau
der Segway Erfinder
ist mit dem Segway von der Klippe gefahren
das ist
das ist auch irgendwie ein
man könnte sagen fast schon ein stylischer Abgang
für den Segway Erfinder
nicht der
der Eigentümer
ja Segway gibt es nicht mehr
die waren
vor Elektroroller und haben versucht
Elektroroller zu verbreiten
und es hat nicht geklappt
decade from just inadequate
too catastrophic
spoiler alert
this is the first time we've ever had a 10 out of 10 fail
on one of these lists
also schieß los
LG revolutionized the way that humans interacted with robots
just
das kann ja schon mal nicht funktionieren
ist laut genug oder soll ich ein bisschen lauter machen
oh das war Dave
Dave da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
das kommt mir noch bekannt vor
never in my life
have I seen excitement
turn into so much cringe
I want to disappear into my chair
this quickly
he asked a question to it
and for five of the longest seconds of my entire life
the whole audience just sat there
eyes wide waiting to see what this
next generation of robots was about to do
we're still waiting
but it only started to get really awkward
when he then tried again
for a second time
Chloe what's for dinner tonight
fair play
he tried to play it off like the robot was just angry at him
but by the time he got
hast du ein stream deck
nee hab ich nicht
stream deck overrated
ich hab ein paar Elgato dinge aber stream deck
wüsste ich jetzt nicht wozu ich das brauche
stream deck kann zum Beispiel nicht sowas hier machen
ganz wichtig
what recipes could I make with chicken
the entire audience was just laughing
okay das Ding
das Ding hat es halt ein bisschen verkackt
aber
das Beste ist immer noch
also da wo ich mich früher übelst drüber
kaputt gelacht habe ist die
Bill Gates
presentation
Windows 95 Scanner
wo es crasht
leider scheiß Quali
das gibts
mich wunderts dass es das nicht in
besserer
Quali gibt
das war nicht
das war ursprünglich auch nicht so schlecht
ja gut egal
das war für mich auch richtiger Fail
ob der danach gefeuert wurde
nee
nee nee ich glaub das war
oh ich hab vergessen wie er heißt
ich glaub das war der Windows Dude
äh steht da denn?
ist da ein Name dabei?
nee nee nee nee
ich glaub das ist der Windows Mann
ich hab vergessen wie er heißt
der ist immer noch da und der war auch danach
noch am Start
keine Ahnung ich kenn mich Microsoft
historisch nicht so gut aus
der wurde definitiv nicht gefeuert
der war lange
nee Ballmer das ist nicht der Ballmer
ach nee Polmer
nee nee
also der Ballmer
den erkennt man
Ballmer ist Developers Developers Typ
ey das ist eines der cringesten
das ist echt
das cringigste aller Zeiten
es will keiner mitklatschen
die klatschen nur mit
weil die sich denken
der Verrückte hört eh nicht vorher auf
bis wir mitklatschen
Developers
das ging ja in Wirklichkeit
in Wirklichkeit ging das ja noch viel länger
das ging ja noch viel länger
der Typ hat so krass
Dachschaden gehabt
mittlerweile hat er doch ein eigenes
Base ne äh Basketball
Team oder?
Basketball Base Basketball glaub ich
was heißt Web Developers
Web Developers
Hahaha
oh man
der Typ hat echt
Schaden gehabt
naja das ist der
der hat immer so geschwitzt auf der Bühne
das ist der der angeblich
als jemand gekündigt hat
und ähm
gesagt hat er wechselt zu Google
angeblich den Stuhl
durch den Gang ihm nachgeworfen hat
oder den Stuhl aus dem Fenster
geworfen hat ich krieg die Story
ich krieg die Story nicht mehr ganz zusammen
zumindest hat er mit dem Stuhl rumgeworfen
der war halt fertig
der war halt relativ schnell
auf 180
der BitConnect Typ
ja der BitConnect Typ der macht das ja nur
rein für Stonks
der hatte sogar ein Video danach aufgenommen
so ok gucken wir mal weiter
Coder oder Developer
na Coder ist kacke
kein Softwareentwickler
kein Coder
weil mal ganz im Ernst
das auch
meinetwegen Programmierer
aber das was du
als Programmierer
eigentlich
am wenigsten am Tag machst
ist wirklich Programmieren
du machst dir eigentlich zu
zu mindestens
70% der Zeit Gedanken darüber
was du Programmieren
könntest und wie
und das eigentliche Programmieren
ist dann
die
ja
der kleinere Teil davon
oder du kannst Stack Overflow Copy Pasten
was ich ja bevorzuge
einfach Stack Overflow Driven
programmieren
und 70% wird eh gemietet
ich mein du musst ja das Daily Stand Up
dein Tribe Meeting
und die Change Runde
und alles mögliche musst du ja schon machen
ja
also das Runcible ist
was du bekommst wenn du diese Konvention
oder wirklich um mehr spezifisch zu sein
es ist was du bekommst wenn du jede Konvention
es war das weltweit erstes zirkuläre Smartphone
es hat die Glaskonstruktion für Holz
es war sogar vollständig User Upgradable
was ist das
es konnte einfach keine Telefonanrufe machen
wenn du die kleine Printe auf der Website schaust
sie bezeichnen es als ein sehr kleines Tablet
was ist das
Moment Moment
was was was was ist das
hab ich nicht gecheckt
was soll das sein
aus das sieht aus wie ein china gadget mit dem esp 32 drin also also noch
schlimmer das sieht eigentlich aus wie eine rgb led von innen nur ohne die rgb
leds drin also wisst ihr dieses runde dieses runde bord was in rgb lampen
trenne ist so sieht das aus
ich glaube das ist der nazi bot
schau doch eine nachricht oben ich weiß nicht was
das ist halt auf twitter
ach das ist cybertruck ja wobei man da bis heute nicht weiß ob es fail oder absicht ist
ne?
ach das ist cybertruck wobei man da bis heute nicht weiß ob es fail oder absicht ist ne?
ja ich bin mir nicht ich bin bis heute nicht sicher ob das ob das absicht war oder oder oder
fail
guck mal der haut ja auch gar nicht richtig fest drauf
na doch doch
äh das ist gummi
ja jetzt gehts gleich kaputt
м
ich könnte mir vorstellen das das absicht war. Keine ahnung.
Gut, hey, wenn der das sagt, im Nachhinein, würde ich das nicht glauben, weil, was, jetzt mal ernsthaft, versetzt euch mal rein, ihr kündigt so ein Ding an, es geht kaputt, das einfachste, was man danach sagt, ist, ja, das war Absicht.
Das heißt, das aus der Quelle glauben kann man schon mal nicht. Und außerdem sagt er viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, das stimmt. Aber ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass das Absicht war.
Wie gesagt, nur weil Elon das konfirmt, heißt es nicht lange nicht, dass das so ist.
Ah, ah, Google Friedhof.
Glass? Alter, Glass.
Das ist also das Einzige, was ich mir gemerkt habe in puncto Google.
Google Glass war diese Story, dass der Google-Gründer was mit der Glass-Entwicklerin hatte.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich mir bei der ganzen Glass-Story gemerkt habe.
Ja, das hat ja bis zum Schluss nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das war zu früh. Google versuchte, die digitalen und physischen Welten zu verbinden.
Bevor die Technik rauskam.
Und so für fast alles, was man tun könnte, hatte es nur einen massiven Asterisk daneben.
Man kann sich wahrscheinlich vorstellen, dass dieses ganze Konzept, $1.500 zu droppen, um effektiv ein Produkt zu testen, das alles, was dein Handy macht, machte, aber nicht besser, nicht gut mit dem übrigen Konsumenten.
Und der letzte Google-Blunder, zumindest für dieses Video, ist Stadia.
Ich erinnere mich, als ich dieses Ding erkannt habe.
Diese ganze Idee, dass du einfach nur ein paar Spiele auf YouTube schaust und, wenn du es magst, einen Knopf drückst und dich in das Spiel selbst einsteigst.
Die Stadia.
By the way, wollen wir mal wieder gucken, wie die Nutzerzahlen von Stadia sind?
Nee, müssen wir nicht. Die sind immer noch unten.
Nee, es hat ja... Nein, nein, nein, Leute. Es gibt kein Input-Lag bei Stadia.
Input-Lag. Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Negative Latency.
Das ist... In Wirklichkeit ist es doch... Das haben wir doch gelernt von denen.
In Wirklichkeit ist es bei Stadia doch schneller, als wie wenn es bei dir lokal läuft.
Negative Latency.
Wie kann das sein, dass es Input-Lag gibt?
Das haben die... Das ist jetzt kein Witz, den ich mache.
Das haben die Stadia-Leute wirklich gesagt.
Das haben die wirklich gesagt.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, negative Latency. Das denke ich mir jetzt gar nicht aus.
Und das haben die... Okay, die haben das begründet und das war sogar relativ sinnvoll, was sie gesagt haben.
Sie haben gesagt, was sie damit meinen ist, dass wenn du Multiplayer-Spiele spielst,
dann musst du nicht mehr quasi von deinem Rechner zum Server und zurück,
sondern die Spieler wären ja alle auf dem Server und die Latency wäre dadurch quasi schneller.
Was aber schwachsinnig ist, weil dein Input und Output, der muss ja immer noch zu dir hin.
Zum... Da... Dorthin und zurück.
Also, er ist bescheuert, er ist... Aber gut, Stadia, Stadia halt noch.
Every time I press a key on my controller, that command has to be transmitted wirelessly to my computer.
It's then got to find its way all the way towards the servers that are hosting this game,
which were often not close at all, process that command to produce an output
and then send that next frame all the way back down to my computer so that I can see what's happening next.
Or to put it in a more visual way, this is kind of what the gameplay looked like.
And this is...
This is on a high-speed internet connection.
Input lag was only one of Stadias many problems, but we do need to cover other things in this video today.
Ja, zum größten Teil... Zum größten Teil hat das ja halbwegs funktioniert,
aber es hatte halt einfach keine wirklichen netz... so... riesige Vorteile, wo die Leute gesagt hätten, ja, das ist es.
Like, the Wii U.
Huch, made it.
Thank you.
You remember the Wii, right?
Hey, die Wii U war gar nicht kacke. Ich fand die Wii U nicht kacke.
Nintendo hat die nur unglaublich dämlich vermarktet.
That console, even though it was about as powerful as my fridge, it changed gaming forever.
It was the first time that I'd ever seen three-year-old kids playing the same games as their 70-year-old grandparents,
with both groups loving each other.
Das Problem an der Wii U war, dass die Leute nicht gecheckt haben, dass es eine neue Konsole war.
Crazy that Nintendo could go straight from highs like this...
Kennst du doch Ouya? Oh ja, ja, ja, das kenn ich noch.
...to lows like this.
Six years after the Wii, they decided it was time for its next-gen successor.
A console that you could just play normally, on your TV,
but also with the option to play the entire games using just this new controller with its built-in screen.
Eigentlich war die Idee nicht schlecht.
I don't think it was a terrible idea.
It's just, it was executed with all the elegance of a Galaxy Note 7 moments before explosion.
There were plenty of issues, but I'd say the primary culprit is just the fact that they called it the Wii U.
Ja, genau. Genau das seh ich auch so.
And more importantly, doesn't that just make it sound like it's an add-on for the existing Wii?
Hey, even CNN's first impressions article of the Wii U called it a solid accessory.
Noch kein Hunger, doch.
That's the equivalent of saying the PlayStation 5 is a solid accessory to the PlayStation 4.
Ja.
CNN. So, easy 5 out of 10 fail here.
The Wii U was a colossal flop.
Ja.
And to be honest, if Nintendo hadn't turned things around with the Switch that came after,
this could have been the beginning of the end for them.
Nein. Die machen dann einfach mehr Pokémon-Spiel und verdienen noch mehr Geld.
As we've learned from these videos, you can always do worse.
Was wird bestellt? Ich hab noch was da.
Ich hab noch, lass mal überlegen, ich hab noch Krautsalat von der Burger-Bestellung.
Und ich hab, glaube ich, noch ein paar Nudeln am Start.
Die Burger-Bestellung war ja diesmal ein bisschen mehr.
Ich hab zwei Burger-Menüs bestellt, aber drei bekommen.
2012, this little box was going viral.
Für zwei Personen.
Imagine this lady telling you that she was...
Oh ja! Tioja! Oh nein, da ist er!
Das war auch so ein Fail-Ding.
Und ey, ich...
Ich lob mich ja ungeheuer selbst, was das angeht, ne?
Aber ich hab's auf Twitter damals predicted.
Hab gesagt, das wird im Leben nix, nach zwei Wochen redet auch keiner mehr davon.
Und es war so.
...Console, called the Yu-Gi-Oh, that for just 99 dollars could play tens of thousands of games,
including Minecraft, platformers, shooters...
Tja, nur dass das mit den Rechten so ein bisschen problematisch war.
Und das im Endeffekt, glaube ich, noch nicht mal richtig funktioniert hat, als es dann rausgekommen ist.
Was macht eigentlich die Souljob-Boy-Konsole?
You'd be pretty excited.
I mean, just the idea of a console at that kind of price is unheard of.
And so it's almost not surprising that Yu-Gi-Oh! became the second most funded project on Kickstarter,
with almost nine million dollars behind it.
But when Yu-Gi-Oh! finally shipped, it became very clear that its biggest perceived strength
was also kind of its biggest weakness.
Because it was based on Android, yes, you were getting tens of thousands of games.
But what was kind of glossed over was the fact that these were fundamentally games made for phones.
At the time, in 2012, very few of them had good controller support.
Most of them were just kind of cheaply made with in-app purchases.
Plus, when you blow up games that were made for a 4-inch 2012 phone screen to a 40-inch TV,
people quickly realized that even calling this a current-gen console was really a push.
Alrighty, now for the smart home.
Or, in this case, the...
What's it, it's probably most, most funded, yeah, wahrscheinlich.
Keine Ahnung, weiß es gar nicht.
Stimmt, die Kentucky Fried Chicken-Konsole gibt's ja auch noch.
Boah! What the fuck?!
Das ist eine Saftpresse für 700 Euro!
... und dann eine Abonniere-Karte bezahlen, um diese Sashays von Cutter zu bekommen.
Ah Moment, das ist...
Hä? Hä? Hä?
Was ist es denn?
Wenn da der Saft drin ist, warum brauche ich das Gerät überhaupt noch?
... Früchte zu benutzen.
Willst du das lustige wissen?
Du brauchst die Maschine nicht.
Bloomberg postete ein 1-Minute-Video...
... zeigte, wie sie tatsächlich den gleichen Saft bekommen können, aber schneller.
... indem sie die Sashays mit der Hand abschneiden.
Und dieses 1-Minute-Video hat die ganze Operation beendet.
Und wenn du dieses Video genießt, dann wäre ein Sub zu diesem Kanal...
... süß.
Aber jetzt beginnt es zu werden, dass es gefährlich wird.
Es gibt eine Firma namens JUICE...
... die mit Saft... mit Saft...
... Ladung...
... Smart Ovens...
Moment.
Nee, das ist das nicht.
Es gab doch letztens diese Typen,
die erzählt haben, sie haben...
... einen Kühlschrank gebaut...
... eine Reverse...
... eine Reverse-Mikrowelle.
Wie hießen die Typen nochmal?
Was ja schwachsinnig ist, du kannst...
... eine Mikrowelle nicht reversen.
Wo die gesagt haben, sie haben eine Reverse-Mikrowelle...
... gebaut, die kühlt.
Was an sich schon absolut keinen Sinn ergibt.
Wie hießen die denn?
Das war auch so ein Scam-Ding.
Jetzt weiß ich doch, warum man die Stecker in beide Richtungen...
... reinstecken kann.
Das ist ja ein Artikel.
Aber die Leute haben schnell herausgefunden, dass...
... ihre June-Ovens, zumindest die erste Generation...
... könnten sich spontan aufstellen...
... und sich aufheben.
Verstehe dir mal, wenn du in der Nacht um 2 Uhr...
... im Mittelpunkt sitzt und plötzlich...
... dein Ofen nur 200°C in der Küche...
... unter dem Kühlschrank...
Das ist keine gute Idee.
Das ist ziemlich furchtbar.
Wenn da noch was übrig war,
oder sogar noch Schmuck aus den letzten Essen...
... könnte das genug sein, um ein Haus auf Feuer zu starten.
Ich muss mal nachgucken, was das war.
Reverse...
Reverse Microwave...
Das da, genau!
Like a Reverse...
Das ist so...
Also...
Wer den Scheiß glaubt immer...
Reverse Mikrowelle, Alter!
Wie soll das gehen?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn!
Das ergibt null Sinn!
Du regst quasi...
... letztendlich Wassermoleküle...
... zum Schwingen an in deinem Essen durch die Mikrowelle.
Okay, wie willst du...
... durch Mikrowellen dann dazu...
Also, du packst ja Energie rein...
... dadurch wird es warm.
Aber wie willst du quasi...
... mit einer Sache, wo du Energie reinpacken kannst...
... Energie rausziehen... Hä?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn!
Die sollen mal lieber den Bauer fragen...
... wie man das Ganze schön in Flüssigstickstoff hält...
... wenn man es schnell kann.
Das kann man machen...
... aber nicht mit einer Mikrowelle!
... das kannst du mit diesen Dingen...
... wo du zum Beispiel...
Da hatte doch ein Bauer...
... auch ein Video drüber...
... wo du es kühlen konntest...
... auf der einen Seite...
... und warm wurde auf der anderen...
... und sowas...
... aber das ist ja keine Mikrowelle.
Ein Sicherheitssystem, das Menschen auf Risiko stellt.
Gut gemacht, Amazon.
Sieh, was passiert war, dass diese Kameras...
Kameras erlaubten den Benutzern,
vollständig zu sehen und zu hören, was in jedem Raum, an jedem Zeitpunkt passiert.
Und sicher, das ist unglaublich nützlich.
Ich hab das nicht falsch verstanden.
Die schreiben selbst,
Like a reverse microwave, schreiben die.
Like a reverse microwave.
Also mehr direkter kann man das halt schreiben.
Das ist halt Schwachsinn.
Ich sag, es ist wie eine umgedrehte Mikrowelle.
Es ist keine Umgedrehte...
Es hat mit einer Mikrowelle absolut nichts zu tun.
Ja, man kann das immer irgendwie drehen, dass es irgendwie passt,
aber dann solltest du es anders schreiben.
Ja, dann sollen sie halt einfach schreiben, dass das Ding schnell kühlt.
Aber das hat mit einer Mikrowelle nichts zu tun.
Wie sind deine Erwartungen zum neuen Battlefield noch nicht vorhanden,
weil man nichts zu weiß?
Das Ding macht etwas schnell kalt, dann solltest du es Schockfroster oder so nennen.
Aber nicht Reverse Microwave.
Weil das wirkt, das liest sich wie was, was es schlicht und ergreifend nicht ist.
Ja gut, jetzt über.
By the way, deswegen keine Cloud-Based Kameras bei sich hinstellen.
Das ist das Einfachste, was man machen kann.
Ich hab bei mir auch Überwachungskameras.
Die sind alle geflasht, beziehungsweise alle local only.
Und ich sehe es nicht ein, warum ich mir Kameras hinstellen soll,
die meine Wohnung in die Cloud streamen.
Wozu?
Der einzige Grund, wo ich mir halbwegs vorstellen kann, was das bringt,
ist, wenn man es sich von außen auf der App angucken will.
Aber selbst das kann man anders machen, ohne dass man permanent in die Cloud streamen muss.
...would threaten and sometimes even blackmail the families they were looking at.
There was one famous incident, where there was an old lady in an apartment
and a voice said to her,
tonight you die.
Oh yeah, and also, the Amazon Ring Smart Doorbells,
the accompanying product to the camera is...
Du kannst dich einfach nicht darauf verlassen, dass das irgendwie gewissenhaft gemacht ist,
beziehungsweise nicht irgendwie was drin ist, was du halt nicht haben willst.
Du weißt es halt schlicht und ergreifend nicht bei solchen Cloud-Produkten.
Und die Hersteller sind ja alles andere als an Transparenz interessiert bei sowas.
Im Zweifelsfall wird sowas eher kleingeredet, weil man nicht will, dass es an die große Glocke gehängt wird.
...bursting into flames.
So, quite the duo.
I mean, obviously this wasn't Amazons fault, and they did address it with a software update,
but what a horrendous oversight.
Okay, do you remember when Segways and Hoverboards were like the coolest thing on the planet?
How it finally felt like we'd figured out a solution to...
Segways.
Ich persönlich finde Segways.
Cool.
Aber das hat sich nicht durchgesetzt.
Where did they go?
Well, we found out the hard way that Segways were dangerous.
You lose focus for just one second and you're either in a ditch, a road, or you've already knocked someone over.
Ja gut. Ey, das ist im Auto auch so.
Du musst halt gucken, was du machst.
Oder auf dem Fahrrad oder sonst wo. Ich find die Dinger cool.
Du musst halt gucken, wo du fährst und was du machst.
Even the President of the United States was seen for it.
Falling off one of these.
And this right here shows when a cameraman managed to plow straight into Usain Bolt,
the world's fastest sprinter.
Or at least he was before that.
What the...
Where did they go?
You lose focus for just one second.
Ich muss mir das gerade nochmal angucken.
And this right here shows when a cameraman managed...
Ja gut.
Der Typ ist halt...
Also, hätte der keinen Segway gehabt,
dann wäre der da drüber gestolpert und aufs Maul gefallen.
Ja gut, ja.
Das war jetzt das, was ich gerade ausgedacht habe.
Und so, so, so.
Das glaube ich ihm nicht.
Das glaube ich ihm nicht, das hat sich gerade ausgedacht.
Really surprising that a lot of governments got involved.
Like, he's the only one who's involved in this.
And the only one who's involved in this.
Yeah, they don't.
He's the only one who's involved in this.
So, so, so, so.
What the hell is going on?
Was ist passiert?
So, so, so.
Fuck!
Wonka, smog!
Das zockt!
Ja.
Ich erinnere mich noch. Dunkel.
Okay.
Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern. Scheint's nicht lang gemacht zu haben.
Hast du nen Facebook-Account? Ja.
Auf dem Facebook-Account steht aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Passt mal auf. Ich bin mir selbst nicht so sicher, warum das da steht.
Äh.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen steht da, dass ich Powered by Alienware bin.
Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, dass ich jemals Powered by Alienware war.
Noch das...
Ich wollte mal. Ich wollte mal.
Ich wollte mal mit denen was machen. Da ist es aber nie dazu gekommen. Also...
Vielleicht habe ich das geändert, so nach dem Motto, guckt mal, so könnte es aussehen.
Ähm.
Keine Ahnung. Benutzen denn andere noch ihren Facebook-Account?
Nee.
Ah, Facebook benutzt doch eh kein Mensch mehr.
Warum machst du denn das Alienware nicht weg? Da müsste ich mich einloggen und da kriegen alle ne Nachricht, dass ich das, äh, Banner geändert hab und...
Tomtricks, dankeschön für den Sub.
It wasn't good.
In fact, it was actually referred to as the worst tech device of the year.
And it was kind of a turning point for a lot of people who realized that they did not trust Facebook.
Das stimmt.
And what makes it...
Das stimmt. Facebook, dieser Facebook-Datenskandal und der Umgang, das war eines der wenigen Dinger, wo ich echt das Gefühl hatte, es hatte Auswirkungen drauf.
Vielleicht weil es auch einer der ersten richtig großen in dieser Art und Weise war, bei einem richtig großen Anbieter.
Mittlerweile sind die Leute so abgehärtet, das juckt einfach kein mehr.
Ach wie, zwei Millionen Kundendaten verloren, auch egal, YOLO, ihr kriegt weiter mal ein Zeug.
Aber, ähm, Facebook ist ja mittlerweile nur noch bei irgendwelchen Boomer-Leuten am Start, die da unlustige Sachen posten.
Das Schlimmste ist, dass in einem Interview, weniger als sechs Monate später, Mark Zuckerberg selbst, wenn er versucht hat, ein Beispiel dafür zu geben, was man als...
Das letzte, das letzte Mal an Ostern, hab ich echt das...
cringigste...
des...
den cringigsten...
Boomer-Facebook-Post aller Zeiten gesehen.
Was mich mal wieder dazu gebracht hat, dass Facebook echt...
noch nie meine Welt war, und die Leute, die da sind, will ich nichts mit zu tun haben.
Da hat einer auf Facebook gepostet...
Zu Ostern...
An Ostern sucht man keine Eier, man spielt mit Eiern.
Und so ein doofes Emoji drunter, das war so ein ultra dummer Boomer-Post.
So ein richtiger Pains-Champ-Post.
Das...
Das ist so ein typischer, dummer...
Facebook-Boomer-Gruppen-Post, alter.
Richtig cringe.
Seitdem hab ich Facebook nie wieder aufgemacht.
Also, ich hab Facebook auch vorher nie aufgemacht, aber...
nicht mal bei Suchergebnissen klick ich's noch an.
Könnte mein Vater sein, ja...
Theoretisch meiner auch, vom Alter her.
Facebook ist mittlerweile nicht mal...
nicht mal wirklich Boomer-Buck, weil...
Boomer ist ja mittlerweile heute quasi fast schon jeder über 30 oder über 35.
Facebook ist 60 plus Buck mittlerweile.
Er sagte, wir wollen definitiv keine Gesellschaft, in der es eine Kamera in jedem Wohnzimmer gibt.
Und während wir da sind mit Facebook...
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht an die letzte Januar-WhatsApp-Update.
Die kamen komplett aufs Blau mit einer Notifikation, die sagte, dass ihre Terms der Service geändert worden sind.
Und wisst ihr, was sich ändern wird? Nichts.
Sie könnten das ein bisschen besser beurteilen.
Was sie herausgefunden haben, war, dass diese Update WhatsApp mit Facebook teilen konnte.
Und...
Die Leute waren furchtbar.
Weil, natürlich, die Implikation war, dass...
auch wenn du denkst, dass du einen privaten Chat mit jemandem hast,
diese Daten sind nicht nur nicht privat,
sondern es wird tatsächlich benutzt, um dir noch mehr schreckliche Akkuraten zu geben.
Aber wer vorher davon ausgegangen ist, dass in einem privaten WhatsApp-Chat die Sachen wirklich privat sind,
der...
dem kann ich auch nicht helfen.
Adverts.
Now, given the reputation that Facebook already had at this point,
they did not need this.
Millions of users started boycotting WhatsApp,
and millions not just uninstalled it,
but went to competing apps like Signal.
Ja, aber es wird sich...
Es wird sich...
Es wird sich aber nichts ändern.
Die Leute gehen jetzt zu alternativen Messagern,
stellen fest, da ist keine Sau und gehen wieder zurück zu WhatsApp.
...social group to do the same.
Fun fact, I actually got asked...
WhatsApp sagt, es hat End-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungen.
Alles, was man bisher gesehen hat, scheint das auch so zu sein.
Aber...
Wer weiß, ob morgen ein Update gepusht wird,
wer weiß, ob da nicht doch irgendwo eine Hinterhüter drin ist,
du hast keine Ahnung im Endeffekt
und kannst du nicht haben, wenn du solche Plattformen verwendest.
...on Radio, here in the UK...
Tatsächlich, man kommt an...
an so un...
an so Third-Party-Plattformen,
du kommst heute nicht mehr dran vorbei,
du kannst dein Leben nicht komplett ohne mehr führen, aber...
oder...
zumindest schlecht.
Ähm...
Aber man kann das auch übertreiben,
also man muss auch nicht bei jeder Sache mitmachen
und da sein Zeug scheren.
...dann muss man auch mit Menschen sprechen,
über die besten Apps, die man schalten kann.
Und WhatsApp kam danach raus und sagte,
hey, Leute, es war eine Ververstörendung,
wir wollten das nicht tun,
wir teilen keine Daten mit Facebook,
aber das macht es fast mehr zu einem Fehler.
Sie haben eine riesige Teil der Userbase genutzt,
nur weil sie ihre Wörter nicht klar machen konnten.
Das stellt das indefinite 7 aus 10-Territorium ein.
Und dann...
Gibt's Knuddels noch?
...haben wir noch viel zu danken für auf YouTube.
Ich meine, sie sind die einzige Grund,
warum ich hier sitzen kann.
Welchen Messenger benutzt du hauptsächlich?
Discord.
Discord für die Arbeit Teams.
Und ich hab...
ich hab Signal installiert,
aber nur, weil wir da mal eine Gruppe auf der Arbeit hatten.
Und der hat mich gleich wieder dazu gebracht,
dass ich diesen ganzen Kack nicht will, ne?
Äh, die machen ja...
die machen ja ein bisschen auf ähm...
Privacy und sowas.
Und das erste, was passiert ist,
dass mich zwei Tage später
kommt im Büro jemand
und meint, hey Max, du bist jetzt auch bei Signal.
Sag ich, hä?
Woher weißt du das denn?
Und er meinte, ja, ich hab ne Benachrichtigung bekommen,
dass du jetzt angemeldet hast.
Einfach so.
Ich hab extra meine...
Ich hab extra am Anfang gesagt,
ich will meine Kontaktdaten nicht sharen.
Also totaler...
totaler Rotz.
...talk to you like this.
It's amazing.
But the one thing that I think we can agree isn't
is rewind.
Lass, lass mal überlegen.
Was könnte denn...
Okay, was könnten denn...
Was könnten denn die ersten Fails sein?
Also Stadia haben wir schon.
Also Google Plus.
Google Plus ist auf jeden Fall mit dabei.
Bei den Top-Fails.
Google Plus muss dabei sein.
Ähm...
Chat, was fällt euch denn so ein?
Es gab jede Menge Fails, aber so spontan...
Es gibt so viele.
Spontan fällt mir da gar nicht so viel ein jetzt.
Also wie gesagt, Google Plus muss dabei sein.
Das geht gar nicht anders.
Ja, mal gucken.
Windows Phone.
Ja, das hat ja wenigstens funktioniert.
Also Google Plus ist auf jeden Fall dabei.
But the one thing that I think we can agree isn't...
Internetausbau in Deutschland.
So it's become a bit of a tradition that once per year YouTube creates a mashup of the
most memorable moments that happened on YouTube.
And people used to love it.
Just being able to see your favorite influencers who never normally would have interacted dancing
together in a room.
It's like a really fun version of an award ceremony.
But YouTube has progressively killed that sentiment.
Instead of the usual 95% like-to-dislike ratio, as soon as we hit 2016, people started
disliking Rewind.
This video had something like 87% likes, which is enough to know that something's off.
But then 2017...
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich weiß, ich hab Rewind noch nie geguckt.
...8% likes and 2018 had 13.8% likes.
War das das?
War das das, wo sie PewDiePie nicht einlagten?
Wollten aus irgendwelchen Gründen?
Oder was war das denn?
Irgendwo wurden sie doch mal richtig hardcore geflamed für...
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Die Xbox One war bei Release auch ein Fail, ja.
The most disliked video on the entire internet.
How does YouTube themselves go that wrong?
Well, it seems like the answer is that they've become disconnected from their creators.
Like, this 2018 Rewind, it started with Will Smith.
Ja, der hat ja sehr viel mit YouTube zu tun.
...because they thought, well, this will make us seem legit.
Fortnite and Marques Brownlee.
But actually everyone watching this was just thinking, why is Will Smith, actor, in a YouTube Rewind?
Ja, das frag ich mich auch.
And the whole video just went on about a bunch of stuff that was kind of significant, but it ignored an alarming amount of the really big stuff.
Maybe YouTube just wants YouTube to seem like a really family-friendly platform.
And so they skipped over all the drama...
...and the controversy.
But as far as the viewer and as far as the creators are concerned, that's what makes YouTube YouTube.
And so Rewind started to feel less like a one-off super special video.
Äh, wir haben ja auch unser eigenes Cringe-Format.
Kennt noch jemand diesen Videopreis, diesen deutschen Dings da, Videopreis?
Ich hab vergessen, wie der heißt, schon wieder.
Dieses, diese Schwachsinnsveranstaltung.
...that everyone got amped up for.
More just like a feel-good PG-rated trailer for YouTube as a service.
And don't even get me started on the 2019 Rewind, which was just a countdown of videos that did well.
And the 2021? It didn't actually happen.
So, you know how it feels like everyone under the age of 30 is on Instagram and TikTok right now?
Well, in some alternate universe, they'd all be on an app.
Wart mal, was war das denn nochmal?
It stands for Quick Bytes.
It was meant to be the Netflix for the up-and-coming generation.
Where it was still big-budget content, but capped at 10 minutes in length.
Was war denn das nochmal?
The idea being that, more and more, we're consuming content in shorter bursts.
We are less about now sitting down for two hours at a time watching an entire film,
more about spending 10 minutes here watching a couple of TikTok videos,
spending 10 minutes here flicking through an Instagram feed.
So, this was quasi...
Die haben halt, glaube ich, alle noch nicht gecheckt,
dass gerade viele Jüngere da sind.
Dass gerade viele Jüngere, die wollen gar nicht mehr so sehr klassischen
und auch von irgendwelchen Studios produzierten Content sehen.
Ich meine, warum ist denn TikTok so erfolgreich?
Guckt euch mal an, bei uns versuchen ja auch die ganzen Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
jetzt mit irgendwelchen YouTube-Channels, die sie sich entweder einkaufen,
Corporations machen oder neu gründen, irgendwas auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Da sind ein paar ganz gute Sachen ab und zu dabei.
Aber zum größten Teil ist es hoffnungslos.
Wir versuchen, ein paar Leute zu erreichen,
die uns halt auf unserer klassischen Plattform komplett abhanden gekommen sind.
Ja.
...to replace that time.
And it was packing heat.
It was led by Meg Whitman, ex-CEO of HP,
and Jeffrey Katzenberg, chairman of...
Ja, die sehen ja auch vom Alter her exakt so aus,
als wissen die, was junge Leute gucken wollen.
...in these studios.
And together, these guys managed to raise
$1.7 billion in funding.
The failure came though, because this was like
an older person's view of what younger people want.
Genau.
It was built for the 20 to 35 age group,
but by people who were over 60.
Yeah.
What they needed to do was to get those same YouTubers and TikTokers
that this generation was engaging with
to create special high production value content for them.
But what they actually did was to just get a whole load
of A-List Hollywood celebrities instead.
People...
...because of star-studded chats.
...don't get...
...mean wrong,
but I think they misjudge their audience.
I also think that...
...and I also think that...
...showing that, you know,
I don't know if I need to explain it
because I think you kind of sing-and-sing it right now,
but I think that the thing is,
when you're being, like, screened,
where people are like this,
it's kind of different for you.
How in the world are...
eigene Sendung, eigene Shows, eigene
bekannte Leute, ob es so
wirklich
da noch so wirklich so was wie Michael Jackson
mal gibt oder so, den quasi auf der ganzen Welt
jeder kennt. Weiß ich nicht,
ob es das in Zukunft noch so bestimmt
noch vereinzelt, ja.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so irgendwie
500 Leute oder so.
Quibi hat man das
ausgesprochen.
Schreckt.
Okay, das
hätte ich ja nicht so
wie vorgestellt.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich.
Meiner, meiner nicht, meiner nicht.
We've hit the jackpot. They were throwing
money in their direction. And
because it's Bitcoin we're talking about,
these transactions are irreversible.
So, which group of
masterminds came up with this?
Three teenagers.
And thankfully all they wanted was to earn some
quick money, because if this was done by
someone with more malicious intentions,
with that kind of power, the
ability to speak on behalf of anyone in the world,
you could start a war.
So, 8 out of 10 fail
for this one. Now,
in any list of tech fails
made in 2020.
Bis, weiß man denn heute, wie die das geschafft haben?
...
We can't not talk about cyberpunk.
For those of you who don't know about it,
this was the biggest... Ach, Games hat
er auch drinne. Ja, okay, da fallen mir
noch ein paar Fails ein.
...of the entire decade. They had only just released a couple of
months ago, but... Sixteen times
the detail.
...since 2013. And sure,
I mean, if it's that revolutionary, we'll
wait seven years after seeing the first trailer.
But, this wasn't that.
And I don't think anybody would have predicted
how badly it was gonna backfire.
In a very best case scenario,
you got a buggy mess.
We're talking random teleportations,
ridiculous graphical glitches, people flying
through walls, and pretty much everything else
you can think of. But worse still,
if you bought this game on a last gen
Playstation 4 or Xbox One,
which I imagine most people did,
then it looked and ran
about as good as me after Uber Eats went
50% off. And it's not just
the fact that when this game launched, it wasn't
even close to ready. It's the fact that
the company that created CD Projekt Red,
they tried to hide it.
They restricted access to early copies,
so reviewers couldn't even warn
people. So, you can probably imagine
that when all of this was completed, the best
price plummeted.
They got demolished on social media.
They had multiple class action lawsuits filed
against them. But the worst bit,
these guys were
maliciously hacked.
Stimmt.
...and it's tough to say for sure whether this was linked to the game.
Das habe ich schon wieder voll verdrängt.
...but it would be a
pretty huge coincidence if not.
Someone got into their servers and basically took
every bit of secretive data they could find.
Das hatten wir doch eben gerade schon mal.
Das mit Coder oder Developers hatten wir doch schon mal
vor 20 Minuten oder so.
...their employees,
their accounts, and even the source code
of the game, which can be used
to create an unlimited number of new copies
of it. And then the hackers
sold all that information.
Cyberpunk is the biggest
video game disaster,
die ich jemals in meinem Leben gesehen habe.
9 aus 10 Fälle.
Nun, wir haben schon einige alarmierende Dinge auf dieser Liste gesehen.
Einige Dinge, die dich fürchtet.
Aber stell dir vor, dass du dich fürchtest,
wenn du diese Nachricht auf deinem Handy gesehen hättest.
Stimmt!
Ja, das kommt mir noch bekannt vor.
Da klingelt bei mir im Kopf irgendwas.
Da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Siehst du, in der Schelter, das ist kein Drill.
Das war eine Nachricht, die ich im Jahr 2018
an jede TV, Radio und Smartphone in Hawaii geliefert habe.
Die Leute waren bereits auf der Ecke,
weil die Pensionen seit Jahren mit Nordkorea aufgetreten sind.
Und beide Länder hatten nukleare Waffen.
Also war das eine sehr echte Bedrohung.
Die Leute mussten ihre Gedanken verlieren.
Aber es war ein Fehler.
Das ganze war nur eine interne Misskommunikation
in der Hawaii-Emergenz-Fazilität.
Und es hat sie 38 Minuten gedauert.
38 von den wahrscheinlich am freundlichsten,
hellischen Minuten dieser hawaiianischen Leben,
um sie zu korrigieren.
Gleich in den Keller.
Es muss, okay, Google Plus ist bis jetzt noch nicht gekommen.
Na, es muss Google Plus sein, Leute.
Google Plus muss auf der Eins sein.
Postchamp.
Okay, das stimmt.
Warum war da Google Plus?
Okay, die haben es aber auch verdient.
Die haben es auch verdient.
Vor allem, dass sie wirklich Leute damit getestet haben.
Und auf einmal Leute angeblich irgendwie,
was weiß ich,
einen Gehirntumor hatten,
die vollkommen gesund waren und sowas.
Ey, Alter, Alter.
Das ist die,
die versucht hat, immer so tief zu sprechen,
in irgendwelchen Interviews.
Had aber nicht funktioniert.
Hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Ein Inspiration.
Sie wurde oft übertragen,
als die frage,
steve jobs das problem finde ich ist gar nicht mal so sehr dass es nicht funktioniert hat das
ist natürlich so das grundlegende problem aber das problem ist er das ist auf das dass diese
komplette kette versagt hat ich meine die haben ja ernsthaft leute damit getestet und haben dann
gesagt sie sind todkrank obwohl sie nichts hatten herr company mit 9 billionen dollars
ich denke der ps5 bridge you could build with that but is all founded on lies right from the
very beginning this machine did not do what she said it did she claimed to investors that it
had been used in the military and that it had been used in emergency rooms but it hadn't best
there are no company they didn't even themselves use these machines they would tell these investors
yes sure of course we can give you a demo of our tech and they would take their blood samples go
into a back room and test it using conventional methods
actually use one of these machines to get their blood results was very likely misdiagnosed
severity of being told that you have cancer when you don't or even worse being told that
you don't when you do this is bad yeah so bad that the entire company had to shut down so
bad that elizabeth holmes is on trial so bad that there's an award-winning documentary made
about her scam and even apparently an entire feature film in the works with jennifer lauren
is playing as her i think this is worthy of a 10 out of 10 fail okay by the time i finish this
sentence you have watched me make my very own thai green curry excellent you get your your powder
you mix it into water and leave it also wenn ich thai curry essen will dann noch nicht als pulver
five minutes this is not a protein shake or a liquid meal replacement it is an actual meal
that you can have for lunch or dinner
just good ingredients and if you didn't know i've actually been having fuel myself for four
years before the company actually reached out and wanted to sponsor a video because
fundamentally it fits well in my life i care about my health okay okay das ist jetzt das
muss nicht sein das muss ich dann braucht man dafür auch so eine extra presse dass man das
rauspressen kann das für 700 euro weil ich habe übelst kohlen ab ich glaube ich gehe jetzt kommen
ich bin länger angewiesen als sonst obwohl ich kopfweh habe gibt es irgendjemanden den man
hosten kann ist der frasier am start sag mal wen kann ich hosten der frasier ist nicht am start
okay ich guck mal kurz in meine follow list ob irgendeiner dabei ist keiner da kenn ich nicht
ne keiner da den ich kenne nicht ne keiner da den ich kenne nicht ne keiner da den ich kenne nicht
kennen
leute schön dass so viele dabei gewesen sind 470 leute huge poggers wir sehen uns macht's gut
nächsten stream wer nicht gefoltert hat und ihm das gefallen hat ich mache jeden sonntag so ein
stream mit der eine runde folgen können wir auf youtube twitter vorbei gucken und sellout beendet
wir sehen uns bis denn ich gebe als essen also macht's gut